Wir wollen blicken auf den europäischen Top-Fußball, auf die Premier League mit Uli Hebel, auf die Serie A mit Christian Bernhard und auf La Liga mit Alex Truica. Und genau jetzt geht's los. Schneidet euch an.
Und nun im Programm, der Rasenfunk. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Wenn ich nur lang genug warte mit diesem Intro, dann wird es irgendwann richtig schön Retro. Also freuen wir uns schon mal in 10 Jahren drauf. Guten Morgen liebe Herren hier in der Runde. Nachdem wir schon geklärt haben, warum ich ein Boomer bin, freue ich mich, dass wir jetzt über die wirklich wichtigen Dinge reden. Guten Morgen.
Guten Morgen, Junge Mann.
Hallo Junge Mann. Ich wollte den gleichen Job machen.
Tja, zu spät, sage ich dazu nur. Aber das war ein optischer Witz, den nicht mal die Leute über YouTube verstehen, liebe Podcast-Hörende da draußen.
Ach, what's up, what's up.
Ja gut, aber sie kennen...
Es gibt immer eine oder einen.
Sie kennen ja nicht die Vorgeschichte. Aber gut, wollen wir über Fußball sprechen? Ich glaube, es ist besser. Da kennen wir uns auch insgesamt besser aus. Da sind wir uns denke ich alle einig. Und wenn du magst, Alex, dann darfst du gleich mal beginnen. Lass uns doch mal auf La Liga blicken bzw. auf ein Pokalwettbewerb. Denn ich denke, es haben ja die Allermeisten mitbekommen. Prelek Rino Matarazzo, den wir ja noch sehr gut kennen, von der TSG Hoffenheim und vom VfB Stuttgart. Der hat ein kleines... Ist Fußball-Märchen zu viel geschrieben?
Ja, Märchen weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber eine wunderschöne Story. Also ich weiß nicht, was die Abschwächung von Märchen dann ist. Wenn einfach eine Geschichte sehr, sehr schön ist, sehr rund ist und ja, La Liga-Geschichte bringe ich mit, aber technisch gesehen ist es eben der Pokal, die Copa del Rey. Und ja, Real Sociedad hat diese gewonnen im Finale gegen Atletico und da eine sehr, sehr runde, schöne Story geschrieben. Also nicht nur Matarazzo an sich, sondern wirklich auch der ganze Verein, die Art und Weise, wie das Finale ablief davor danach. War ja eine sehr, sehr schöne Sache. Ich weiß nicht, ob man es in Deutschland jetzt so sehr mitbekommen hat, aber auch dafür sitze ich hier, damit ich ein bisschen davon erzähle.
Das müssen wir auf jeden Fall tun. Also ich habe mir das Elfmeterschießen dann live angeguckt, weil da war gerade irgendwie die Aufzeichnung der Bundesliga-Sendung fertig. Dann habe ich gesehen, oh, es läuft noch. Und dann habe ich tatsächlich mit dem Underdog ein bisschen mitgefiebert, denn La Real hat ja schon länger keine Titel mehr gewonnen. 23 Jahre habe ich mir das richtig gemerkt.
Leider nein. Vor fünf Jahren haben sie den Pokal gewonnen. Also sie hatten in der Corona-Zeit, 2019, 20 müsste das gewesen sein. Das war das Finale gegen den Athletik-Club aus Bilbao. Also das Baskendorbi im Finale konnte damals nicht stattfinden. Wegen Corona wurde um ein Jahr, eineinhalb, einen Viertel verschoben, fand dann 21 statt. Aber ich glaube, ohne Fans wäre ich mich richtig dumm.
Genau, weil ich habe nämlich ein Video gesehen von einem älteren Mann, also quasi in meinem Alter, auch ein Boomer, der auf sein Ticket verzichtet hat, damit seine Tochter ins Stadion gehen kann, weil er beim letzten Triumph eben, also dann beim vorletzten Triumph offenbar vor 23 Jahren mit dabei war und er gesagt hat, sie soll das jetzt auch erleben. Und dann hat man gesehen, wie sie beim Elfmeterschießen oben so an der Ballustrade stand, dass sie zu ihm Signale geben konnte. Und er hat dann quasi von außen das Elfmeterschießen miterlebt. So kam ich nämlich drauf. Und dann ist das wahrscheinlich, weil es keine Fans gab beim letzten Triumph.
Wahrscheinlich, weil es keine Fans gab, genau. Ja, er hatte drei Tickets, dieser Mann, und ist mit seiner Frau und seiner Tochter hin. Und ein Ticket hat ihm den Einlass verwehrt, das ging irgendwie nicht, und dann hat er verzichtet für seine Frau und seine Tochter und blieb vor dem Stadion sitzen und hat es da im Radio gehört. Das ist auch krasse Story, ne?
Ja, aber das ist ja stellvertretend für dieses Pokalfinale, das eben viele schöne Geschichten geschrieben hat. Was ist denn, was glaubst du denn, sollte man darüber wissen?
Ja, ich fange mal anders an. Ich fange mal ganz vorne an. Ich finde es erstmal cool, als der Pokal reformiert wurde, wurde er so geändert, dass die unterklassigen Teams immer Heimrecht haben in jeder Runde. Im Halbfinale wird er dann Hin- und Rückspiel ausgetragen, aber davor haben kleine Teams immer Heimrecht. Also der Zweitligist gegen den Erstligisten, der Drittligist gegen jeden anderen etc. Das finde ich schon mal cool. Dann aus Deutschland kennt man es ja, das eine Finalsstadion, oder aus England natürlich auch, wurde ja auch vor, ich glaube, fünf Jahren war die Reformierung, wurde geändert jetzt im La Catucha in Sevilla, dieses leerstehende eigentlich Olympiastadion. Haben sie jetzt auch umgebaut, die Tatanbahn ist weg. Also das ist eine coole Reform. Endlich einen Endspielort haben und dadurch hast du schon so ein bisschen mehr Mythos, Pokal und dann natürlich das halbe Stadion voll 25.000 Real Sociedad-Fans, 25.000 Atletico-Fans. Letztes Jahr war ich ja beim Klassikor, da war es ja genauso. Also diese Stimmung, die du dann da auch hast, durch den geteilten Fanlager, es ist was ganz Besonderes. Ich glaube, das kommt vielleicht in Deutschland gar nicht so an, aber es ist schon wirklich eine tolle Stimmung auch, weil so viele Fans in Sevilla vor Ort sind, die dann zum Stadion strömen, die ihre eigenen Fanparties haben. Also an sich, der Wettbewerb wurde vom Verband sehr, sehr aufgewertet und bedeutend natürlich Mannschaften sehr, sehr viel, die nicht Real Madrid und FC Barcelona heißen. Die Dauersieger, wobei Real gewinnt es ja gar nicht so häufig, aber die sind halt die Großkopferten, die wissen gar nicht, das so richtig zu schätzen, habe ich oft das Gefühl. Steigen ja auch später Einwege im Supercup und die Mittelklasse-Klubs oder kleineren Klubs, die ist das natürlich die Jahrhundert-Chance auf einen Titel. Andere Vereine, die nicht Real und Basa heißen, gewinnen sehr sehr selten Titel, haben sehr sehr seltene Chance auf Silberware und dadurch ist es erst recht etwas Besonderes. Und das ist jetzt so die Einleitung und dann war das Spiel natürlich auch nicht verkehrt, 1-0 nach, ich weiß gar nicht, 19 Sekunden, ein stimmungsvolles 2-2 auf Augenhöhe, absolut berechtigt, dass es dann auch in die Verlängerung und ins Elfmeterschießen geht. Und dann gewinnt das mal wieder das Ding. Und dann hat man gesehen, was das für die Fans, für den Verein bedeutet, welche Identifikation die Basken ja eh mit ihrem Verein haben. Also ich nehme da Bill Bauer natürlich mit rein. Das ist einfach nochmal was anderes. Das ist so wie eine Familienbande, wie das eigene Blut. Sie sind ja sehr, sehr verbandelt mit ihrem Land, mit ihrem, ihrer Kultur, mit ihrem Verein. Und da hast du gemerkt, das ist nicht nur für irgendeinen Verein einfach jetzt mal ein Titel, sondern da steckt so viel mehr drin.
Und welche Rolle hat denn Pellegrino Matarazzo dabei gespielt? Denn so ehrlich muss man ja sein, er ist ja auch noch gar nicht so lange bei La Real.
Ja, das ist interessant. Ich glaube, der Vereinspräsident hat im Nachgang erzählt, die KI hat ihm abgeraten, ihn einzustellen. Da frage ich mich, welche KI? Wie wird da? Hat er bei GPT, wer ist der beste vereinslose Trainer eingegeben oder so? Das weiß ich nicht ganz, aber es war zumindest eine sehr überraschende Wahl. Also auch für uns vermeintliche La-Liga-Experten wäre ich nicht so drauf gekommen, dass die ihn einstellen. Und war ich schon ein bisschen verblüfft. Und es hat ja funktioniert. Er hat jetzt, ich meine aus dem Kopf heraus, 18 Spiele geleitet, seit er kam, nur drei davon verloren, also Pflichtspiele, nur drei davon verloren in La Liga gegen bei Atletico, beim FC Barcelona und bei Real Madrid. Ansonsten ist er ungeschlagen, wenn ich mich nicht täusche. Und das zeigt ja schon auf, also nicht nur, weil er den Titel gewonnen hat, sondern das funktioniert richtig gut. Die Mannschaft hat in allen 18 Spielen unter Matarazzo immer getroffen. Und wer La Liga ein bisschen verfolgt, weiß, sie hatten riesige Probleme mit dem Torgeschießen in den eineinhalb Jahren zuvor. Also sehr, sehr wenig Torgeschoss, oft zu null, kam vorne nicht durch. Und jetzt ist er da. Sie treffen in jedem Spiel, sie sind fast unbesiegbar und sie gewinnen am Ende sogar den Pokal gegen Atletico als leichter Underdog. Also das hat recht gut funktioniert, dieses Gespür, dass die Vereinsoberen da hatten, als sie Matarazzo einstellten.
Also die dritte Niederlage war gegen Villarreal, gegen Barca hat Matarazzo nämlich sogar gewonnen. Das war doch auch so mit so sein erstes Spiel, glaube ich, was er hatte. Zumindest sehr früh.
Hat man nicht in Barcelona seitdem einmal von da? Ist ja wurscht, aber auf jeden Fall der Rekord spricht für sich. Deswegen nicht nur auf den Pokalsieg beschränken, sondern das funktioniert wirklich gut, seitdem er da im Dezember, Januar, wann auch immer kam. Und eine ganz schöne Story. Und deswegen sage ich ja, vor Stories ist dieser Pokalsieg reich. Er hat sogar auf Baskisch dann die Rede gehalten oder versucht. Er hat es natürlich abgelesen, aber hat versucht, sich da anzupassen und auch auf Baskisch ein paar Worte gesagt, als sie am Rathaus in St. Sebastian gefeiert haben. Also er nimmt das auch richtig auf. Er läuft da immer entspannt durch die Altstadt und begrüßt die Leute und so. Also der ist richtig angekommen. Und jetzt natürlich, ich will jetzt nicht sagen nach dem Märchen, ein Vereinsheiliger, aber er ist schon sehr, sehr schnell, sehr, sehr gut angekommen. Und jetzt durch den Pokalsieg erst recht.
Und sie haben auch gut gefeiert, direkt jetzt gegen Retafel, erster Heimniederlage, seitdem er wieder da ist. Das muss in Ordnung sein, ja.
Ohne Torschuss von Retafel. Es war ein Eigentor, ich glaube, mit dem Kopf ins eigene Tor abgefälscht nach einer Flanke. Retafel hatte keinen Torschuss. Realistische Datt hatte, keine Ahnung, 20. Aber sie waren wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen hangover. Also es gab so Bilder, ich glaube, am zweiten Tag nach den Feierlichkeiten im Training, wo drei Spieler wirklich nicht, nicht taufrisch aussahen. Also die haben gut gefeiert. Das war auch eine ganz, ganz besondere Sache. Übrigens, Feier, da habe ich auch noch eine kleine Side-Story. Aitor Sabaleta, das ist ein Fan, der von den Atletico Ultras vor, ich weiß nicht, wie vielen Jahren, Dekaden umgebracht wurde oder ums Leben kam. Und die Mannschaft hat ein Trikot mit seinem Namen auf dem Pokal gestülpt und hochgehalten. Und ich glaube, es gab ein Taifo, also eine Choreo, auch mit seinem Namen und seinem Konterfeier. Auch da siehst du mal, das ist für die was Besonderes. Dass eine Mannschaft, ein Verein an einen verstorbenen Fan denkt und mit dem feiert, quasi, ihn zu ehren, ein Trikot hochhält, auf dem Pokal stülpt. Es gab so viele Side-Stories, die so schön sind, dass man sich dachte, selbst als neutraler Fan, also ich habe sehr neutral geguckt, das Spiel, dass man sich dachte, da hat die richtige Mannschaft der richtige Verein wahrscheinlich gewonnen.
Also wann? Der ist so sehr dat Fan, weil du gerade Atletico gesagt hast, aber vielleicht war es ein freuter Versprecher, weil du schon gespürt hast. Kurz würde ich ganz gerne noch auf die Situation bei Atletico eben eingehen. Die haben aus ihren letzten acht Spielen nur eines gewonnen und das war eben das 2 zu 0 bei Barca. Ja, und das jetzt ging ja irgendwie mit 2-2 in die Verlängerung, deswegen kann man das ja nicht gelten lassen. Was ist denn los bei Atletico? Ich habe neulich einen internationalen Podcast gehört, wo es auch so ein bisschen Vorschau auf Champions League Halbfinale war da Thema. Und da war die Kurzzusammenfassung, they stink defensively. Also sie können einfach nicht verteidigen.
Ja, es ist nicht das Atletico, das man von den letzten Jahren kennt, wobei sie glaube ich seit zwei Jahren ja schon nie so defensiv solide sind. Also es sind nicht diese, dieses typische Mauer-Atletico, das sich hinten reinstellt und nach 1-0 alles weg verteidigt, die zu Gordien-Zeiten etc. sind, alles ein bisschen her. Nee, sie sind tatsächlich nicht so gut defensiv, dafür offensiv besser. Und Atletico-Spieler sind oft sehr, sehr unterhaltsam. Natürlich haben sie immer Phasen. Wenn sie eine Führung haben, stellen sie sich mal 20 Minuten hinterein und verteidigen die, aber übers ganze Spiel gesehen, das ist nicht der Defensiv-Regel, wie man ihn vor fünf, zehn, acht Jahren kannte. Sie haben Defensiv-Probleme, sie spielen mehr Fußball, sie liegen oft zurück. Allein die Spiele gegen den FC Barcelona in den letzten Jahren, die gingen ja immer wild aus, also nicht nur in diesem Jahr. Das Champions League-Rückspiel, da ging es ja auch nach 30 Minuten, stand schon 2-1. Im letzten Jahr gab es ein 4-4 in Barcelona und ein 4-2 in Madrid. Also Atletico hat Defensiv-Probleme, spielt ein bisschen anders, spielt Forscher. Die Spiele sind oft unterhaltsam. Wenn du jetzt fragst, woran liegt es, dass sie aktuell nicht so gut performen, dann ist in La Liga der Zug nach oben und nach unten abgefahren. Sie sind mehr oder weniger safe in der Champions League auf Rang 3 oder 4. Es spielt keine Rolle, welcher Platz. Dadurch haben sie in der Liga zum Beispiel drei Mal geschont. Da war die Motivation komplett weg. Deswegen sind jetzt drei Niederlagen in Folge. Dann haben sie sich natürlich auf Pokal und Champions League fokussiert. Das waren ja nicht unwesentliche Spiele gegen Barca. So kommt das zustande. Gegen Barca kannst du natürlich auch mal verlieren. Sobald das Pokal-Rückspiel als Champions League-Rückspiel verloren ist, kommen die fünf Niederlagen in sechs Spielen zustande.
Ich würde es auch ein bisschen einordnen. Die sind auf einer Mission in der Champions League. In der Liga kann nichts mehr passieren. Das erklärt vieles. Das Pokalfinale hätten sie sicher gerne mitgenommen. So schlecht stehen sie aktuell nicht da.
Die andere Niederlage war gegen Real Madrid. Auch in der Liga, aber da kannst du auch mal durchaus unglücklich verlieren. Aber es sieht kurios aus, wenn man die Statistik anguckt oder die jüngsten Resultate. Aus Basis Sicht denkst du auch, die verlieren fünf von sechs und genau das eine Gewinne im Kampen kommen nur dadurch weiter. Ja, auch ein bisschen glücklich aufgrund der Umstände. Passt ein bisschen ins Bild bei Atletico.
Aber es ist ganz interessant, wenn du willst, Uli, dann lass uns doch hier das kleine Thema, was wir hatten aus der Premier League mit reinnehmen. Denn wenn sie jetzt gegen Arsenal spielen, muss man ja dann festhalten, auf der einen Seite das Tablos haben wir mit PSG und Bayern zwei Teams, die gerade so aus allen Rohrenfeuern, beziehungsweise PSG jetzt einen kleinen Stolperer dabei gehabt. Aber ich würde schon sagen, die kommen aus einer Position der Stärke. Bei Atletico haben wir jetzt gerade gehört, wie die Situation ist. Nicht ideal zumindest. Und bei Arsenal spitzt es sich ja auch zu. Durch die knappe Niederlage gegen City und jetzt durch das Wiederholungsspiel von gestern Abend ist City auch vorbeigezogen.
Vorgezogen. Also nicht Wiederholung, aber vorgezogen.
Stimmt.
Wegen Pokalfinale. Also wenn man schon mal, ich will nicht alles nur klugscheißen, aber nur das, was wir richtig haben. Aber ja, ist so. Ist keine ideale Situation. City ist jetzt auch bei 70 Punkten, waren bis gestern noch bei 67 Punkten und haben gewonnen. Das heißt, da ist das Momentum komplett auf Seiten Citys. Auch die Leistungen, würde ich sagen. Und bei Arsenal kann man halt jetzt seit ein paar Wochen merken, dass die verstehen, oh, wir können ja was verlieren.
Und steckt dahinter was Größeres? Weil die Tendenz ist ja schon länger jetzt nicht so gut bei Arsenal. Man kann aber dieses Spitzenspiel, was es da gegen City gab, ja, das kannst du ja ganz unterschiedlich interpretieren. Da gab es ja die große Chance noch aufs 2 zu 2 zum Beispiel.
Das Problem ist, also ich muss versuchen, immer das zu untersuchen und sehen, ist da was Strukturelles sozusagen oder ist das gerade ein Leistungsloch oder ist es einfach nur, das wäre der größte aller Punkte, dass denen einmal mehr das Hinternwasser geht. Und ich fand eigentlich, dass der Plan richtig gut war gegen City. Also ich habe das verstanden, dass Harvards wieder spielt, der immer noch nicht bei 100 Prozent wieder ist. Ich habe verstanden, dass Rice und Subi Mendy etwas höher schieben sollen. Langer Ball von Raya in Richtung Harvards gegen die doch relativ kleinen Innenverteidiger von City. Das ist ja nicht unsinnvoll. Das habe ich total verstanden. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, wenn du Rice und Subi Mendy höher schiebst, dann fehlen sie dir halt im Zentrum. Da haben dann Rodri und Silva ihr Unwesen getrieben. Oder einer zumindest, Bernardo Silva. Der brennt vor lauter Form. Das ist Wahnsinn. Rodri ist seltsamerweise seit dem FA Cup-Spiel gegen Liverpool, Viertelfinale, auch wieder da. Jetzt ist er wieder verletzt gewesen gegen Burnley, aber das waren plötzlich wieder Spiele, und ich dachte, ach, schau mal, als wäre nichts gewesen. Und ich glaube, der Punkt ist der, der Attäter probiert gerade ganz, ganz viel richtig zu machen. Ich finde auch, dass er es meistens richtig macht, nur die Ausführung der Systeme ist nicht so, wie sie sein sollte. Und ich kann dir aber nicht sagen, woran es liegt. Es gibt, also, ganz, ganz, so Salibar ist für mich so ein Beispiel. Jemand, den ich total verehre, weil er mit, wahrscheinlich der, also ich hätte immer gerne so gespielt, wie der spielt. Das ist ein sehr kompletter Innenverteidiger aus meiner Sicht. Und seltsamerweise gibt es in dieser Saison 3, 4, 5 Spiele, wo ich richtig sauer bin über den, weil er einfach schwach spielt. Er füllt nicht auf im Mittelfeld zum Beispiel gegen City, was ein Riesenproblem war einfach für die Zusammengehörigkeit des Systems. Als Beispiel, das nächste ist Subhi Mandi, gefällt mir eigentlich seit der Jahreswende nicht mehr so richtig gut. Vermutlich, weil bis dahin war er sehr, sehr stark, vermutlich Rookie-Wall, wie man in England immer so schön sagt, das musst du erst mal können, da im Dezember alle zwei Tage mehr oder weniger zu spielen. Vermutlich, ich weiß es aber nicht, David Reier ist mit Ball am Fuß einfach nur, ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das sagen soll, schlampig überhastet. Auf jeden Fall spielt er einfach nicht genau, sondern er bolzt. Und dann ist natürlich das Problem, auch so, wenn dann Salibar anfängt, dann ist Gabriel, der will dann plötzlich alles übergutmachen. Und ich habe das Gefühl, während City sich da entspannt und Ryan Schakir 3-4 Mal über den Ball drüber streichelt und alle gehen nach links und nach rechts, simpel weg, denkt Arsenal jeden Schritt 5-6 Mal und das spürt man im Moment. Das ist natürlich auch das, was letztlich von den Medien bedient wird. Ihr werdet ja dieses Meme kennen mit diesem Bottle, wo der Fan von Manchester City aus der Arsenal-Flasche trinkt und so tut.
Ich habe nur eine Panna-Bottle da, aus der ich trinken kann. Leider keine Arsenal-Bottle.
Mach das mal nach, ja bitte. Ja, mach das mal nach.
Das wollte ich vorhin schon auspacken, als du das Arschwasser oder das Hinternwasser zitiert hast.
Das ist ja heute eine komische Sendung. Aber fahr fort, Uli.
Da sind viele Anspielungen drin. Ja genau. Und das ist aus meiner Sicht das. Man darf jetzt auch nicht vergessen, wenn man über City gegen Arsenal spricht, das ist schon, finde ich, auf Nuancen basierend, dieses Ergebnis. Und bei Arsenal fehlt halt ein Bukayo Saka, der mit der wichtigste Spieler ist, dessen Output minimal zurückgegangen ist, der aber für mich immer noch wahnsinnig wichtig ist, weil er immer mindestens zwei Leute zieht. Der fehlt und auf Citys Seiten war es nicht ganz so extrem. Da hat eigentlich nur Ruben Diasch gefehlt. Der fehlt in der Regel, haut das richtig rein, wenn der fehlt. Seltsamweise gerade gar nicht so, weil Cousin noch einen Riesenschritt gemacht hat, der auch ein erstaunliches Spiel geliefert hat gegen Arsenal und auch gegen Burnley. Im Übrigen wahrscheinlich so mit der Beste war, weil er genau wie Nunes auch so eine Ein-Mann-Restverteidigung sein kann aufgrund des Tempos. Aber das darf man auch nicht vergessen bei Arsenal, dass Saka gefehlt hat und nicht einer, aber noch jemand hat gefehlt, wo ich mir dachte, Timber hat auch gefehlt. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Nichtsdestotrotz ist das jetzt schon seit ein paar Wochen sichtbar, dass Arsenal– das ist immer so ein bisschen unfachmännisch, das zu sagen, ich habe das Gefühl, jeder möchte alles so überrichtig machen und dadurch gibt es gar keinen Flow. Also im Aufbau gibt jeder noch mal einen Schnörkel. Und dann, ah, Position muss ich korrigieren, zwei Meter nach links, fängt an wieder Freude zu haben und zu spielen. Sie spielen sehr kopfd. Genau, so ein bisschen technokratisch irgendwie. Ich erhoffe mir durch die Niederlage, dass jetzt City diesen, diesen Makel halt weg hatte. Arsenal war jetzt seit 5. Oktober Tabellenführer. Und dadurch, dass das jetzt weg ist, erhoffe ich mir, dass vielleicht Arteta auch wieder eine andere Ansprache wählen kann und sagen kann, so Jungs, jetzt ist es eh weg. Jetzt denkt sowieso das ganze Land, wir verhauen es. Fangen wir wieder an. Jetzt sind wir wieder in der Position, in der wir uns wohlfühlen. Arteta selbst muss man fairerweise auch dazu sagen, ich mag das sehr, aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das nicht insbesondere für junge Spieler so zielführend ist. Der zeigt sich natürlich auch immer mit der Körpersprache immer sehr enttäuscht, wenn was nicht funktioniert. Und sehr fordernd. Und es kann schon sein, dass das den einen oder anderen auch einschüchtert. Das ist etwas, was, glaube ich, in diesem Meisterschaftskampf nicht zu kurz kommen darf. Zumal halt bei– also City fängt jetzt an, Guardiola fängt jetzt an, so minimal zu sticheln. So ganz leicht, nur auch immer im Scherz. Aber man merkt halt, der hat das halt hunderttausendmal so gemacht. Und das ist immer gut gelaufen.
Vorm Spiel hat er ja auch schon gesagt. Wenn wir das verlieren, dann ist es vorbei.
Aber das hat er gegen– ich habe es mir gestern noch mal rausgeschrieben im Vorbereitung auf das Burnley-Spiel. Das hat er Mitte März gegen West Ham auch gesagt. Wenn wir das nicht gewinnen, dann ist der Meisterschaftskampf vorbei.
Genau. Und was er halt diesmal– und was er ja quasi jetzt bei dem direkten Duell, der unausgesprochene Teil ist ja– ja, aber wenn wir das gewinnen, dann sind wir voll mit dabei. Und das ist jetzt nämlich der Fall. Jetzt ist man zum ersten Mal wieder Tabellenführer. Ich habe auch ganz, ganz viele aufgebrachte Skeets gelesen mit dem Restprogramm der beiden. Das sieht schon eher so– also, es sieht eher für City auch so, dass man da durchlaufen könnte. Wenn sie alles gewinnen, dann werden sie mutmaßlich. Die Tordifferenz wird dann entscheiden. Und da ist aber City nicht so schlecht aufgestellt. Deswegen sind sie jetzt ja vorbeigezogen. Plus eben, es gibt halt noch ein Pokal für City. Das ist halt der FA Cup gegen Southampton. Und Arsenal ist aber– wir haben es ja gerade schon besprochen– gegen Atletico in der Champions League mit dabei. Ich finde, es sieht nicht so gut aus für Arsenal.
Ne, es ist so. Ich weiß nicht, ob das so leicht ist und ob so Schalte so leicht umzulegen sind. Aber der Fokus ist immer der. Das habe ich ja immer wieder gesagt. Das ist ein bisschen blöd, weil die sind jetzt Jahr für Jahr zweiter geworden. Aber du könntest als Täter bei Arsenal sagen, schaut mal, wir haben gar nichts zu verlieren. Sondern das kann eine Riesensaison sein. Wir entscheiden jetzt selber darüber.
Aber andererseits 2004 war der letzte Titel, oder?
Ja.
Und sie haben ja auch viel investiert. Also es ist halt, das finde ich schon interessant, wenn man sich Arsenal näher anguckt, wie viel Geld da eigentlich auch geflossen ist in den Kader. Es ist einem nicht so aufgefallen, weil es halt ganz lange sehr wenig Geld war und andere wild investiert haben. Und dann gab es, glaube ich, so zwei Transferperioden. Da haben sie richtig reingebuttert. Da haben wir ja dann auch hier drüber gesprochen. Aber irgendwas sollte dann schon mal dabei herunterfallen. Du willst ja kein Chelsea sein, über die wir später noch reden.
Ja, das ist auch das. Also das finde ich wiederum fast grenzdebil. Aber jetzt wird ja schon auch in England über Atheta gesprochen, ob es überhaupt der Richtige sei und ob man nicht vielleicht mit César Pregas weitermachen sollte oder irgendein anderes Substitut. An der Stelle ist es ja völlig egal. Aber ja, klar, auch Arsenal hat jetzt verstanden, das Fenster ist auf und wir haben ja gesehen, was passiert, wenn man es dann wieder schließt, wie bei Tottenham zum Beispiel. Und da ist natürlich so was wie Angst auch da, dass sie einfach die ewigen Zweiten bleiben und so. Klar, das gibt es.
Wir werden es genau verfolgen, das wird ja auch definitiv noch ein Thema sein. Lass uns dann aber mal auch auf Italien blicken. Da gibt es auch ein Team, das ist in der Champions League ausgeschieden. Aber seitdem läuft es eigentlich ganz gut. Erst noch ein 3-3 bei der Roma geholt. Auch durchaus ein bemerkenswertes Spiel. Und vor allem, wenn ich mir die letzten Ergebnisse angucke, Bernie, da sehe ich dann wieder, ah, die zu Null Spiele. Vielleicht sind sie wieder zurück bei Juve. Wie läuft es denn da?
Ja, schauen wir uns mal Juve an, absolut. Genau, ich würde auch da anfangen, was du schon gerade fallen hast lassen, nämlich dieses 3-3 gegen die Roma. Das hat man damals auch ganz kurz thematisiert. Noch mal zur Erinnerung, da war die Juve lange 3-1 hinten in der zweiten Hälfte, hat dann der Nachspielzeit ausgeglichen. Und wenn sie das Spiel verloren hätten, wäre die Roma in der Tabelle auf plus 7 Richtung Juve gegangen, also im Kampf um die Champions League Plätze. So, jetzt stehen wir da. Jetzt hat Juve fünf Punkte Vorsprung auf Platz 4, also auf Como und die Roma. Hat da jetzt wirklich eine ordentliche Lücke gerissen. Ist sogar im Rennen wiederum Platz 2. Milan und Napoli sind nur drei Punkte entfernt. Jetzt am Wochenende ist auch Milan gegen Juve. Also rein theoretisch können sie da mit Milan gleichziehen. Und ja, deswegen macht es Sinn, sich anzuschauen, wie Spalletti Juve da auf Kurs gebracht hat. Und auch, ich wähle auch deshalb diesen Roma-Anfang, weil ich glaube, es ist kein Zufall, dass sie jetzt in diesen Flow reingekommen sind. So kurz die Zahl dazu. Von den letzten sechs Ligaspielen haben sie fünf gewonnen, einmal unentschieden gespielt und, wie Max ja gerade gesagt hat, dabei nur ein einziges Gegentor kassiert. Und bei dem Unentschieden, bei dem 1-1, hat Locatelli in der 88. Elfmeter verschossen. Also das hätten sie ganz gut gewinnen können. Also Juve hat sozusagen diesem Ergebnisdruck standgehalten, denn das hatten wir damals auch thematisiert. Ui, sind jetzt mitten in diesem Kampf von Platz 4 drin. Wir wissen um die wirtschaftliche Situation von Juve. Also jedem Verein tut es gut, sich finanziell für die Champions League zu qualifizieren. Für Juve ist es schon fast unerlässlich, was sich dann in den letzten Jahren wirtschaftlich hier teilweise für ein negativer Berg aufgebaut hat. Und ja, das haben sie jetzt geschafft. Und deswegen glaube ich, es ist kein Zufall, dass wir über dieses Roma-Spiel am Anfang noch mal reden, denn Max hat sie auch schon gesagt, Juve ist ja da drei Tage davor gegen Galatasaray aus der Champions League ausgeschieden. Das heißt, seitdem hatten sie keine englischen Wochen mehr. Seitdem, seit Anfang März, arbeitet Luciano Spalletti die ganze Woche, Trainingswoche, auf die Liga hin. Und kurz zur Erinnerung, in der Serie A, das ist schon etwas Besonderes, denn die Monate davor gab es es bei Juve so gut wie gar nicht. Also Spalletti kam ja Ende Oktober, hatte die Mannschaft erst während der Saison übernommen und hatte da im Prinzip am Stück nur englische Wochen, weil Juve eben in der Champions League war, weil in Italien es keine Winterpause gab, da wurde über Weihnachten gespielt, da wurde Neujahr gespielt. Im Januar hatte Juve und die Top Clubs, glaube ich, sechs Pflichtspieler, da gab es auch nur englische Wochen, also zweimal die Champions League englischen Wochen, die letzten Spieltage. Aber die Serie A hatte auch noch Nachholspiele unter der Woche. Also was ich sagen will, Spalletti kam eigentlich zu Juve und hatte eine englische Woche nach der anderen. Also konnte so seine Trainingsreize noch nicht so setzen, wie er wollte. Seit Anfang März kann er das. Und deswegen lande ich bei Spalletti, denn Spalletti als Klubtrainer, Spalletti als einer, der tagtäglich mit der Mannschaft arbeiten kann. Das hat er jetzt in den letzten Jahren wirklich sehr unter Beweis gestellt, dass er da wahrscheinlich mit der Beste in Italien ist und auch einer da sicherlich der Besseren in ganz Europa. Und ich finde, das sieht man jetzt, denn viele denken jetzt vielleicht, ja, Juve spielt wieder zu Null, das alte Juve, kein Tor kassieren und dann halt irgendwie eins machen. Aber nein, das ist überhaupt nicht der Fall. Juve ist wirklich unter Spalletti eine spielerische Mannschaft mit viel Esprit. Seit Spalletti Juve übernommen hat, hat nur Inter mehr Punkte geholt. Also sie sind jetzt da auch sozusagen jetzt schon über Monate einfach die Nummer 2 in der Liga. Und ganz interessant, ein paar statistische Daten. Seit Spalletti da ist, hat Juve die meisten höchsten Ballgewinne der Liga, die meisten Abschlüsse nach hohen Ballgewinnen der Liga und die meisten Ballgewinne im letzten Drittel. Also das zeigt, der Ansatz von Spalletti ist auch ein sehr aktiver, dieses Durchschieben, dieses hohe Pressing, um dem Gegner auch Frühzug, Fehlern zu zwingen. Also es ist nicht ein Tiefstehen und Warten und dann Umschalten, wie man es vielleicht von Milan und Allegri kennt, sondern es ist ein sehr aktives Spiel mit Ball sowieso. Das kennen wir unter Spalletti. Erinnern sich vielleicht noch ein paar an die herausragenden Zeiten in Neapel. Also wenn Spalletti-Mannschaften in den Rhythmus reinkommen, dann ist das mit Ball sehr ansehnlich und dazu aber diese defensive Stabilität über sehr hohe Aktivität, über mutiges nach vorne verteidigen. Also Spalletti hat die einfach total auf Kurs gebracht und das ist auch ganz interessant, wenn wir uns die letzten Spiele anschauen. Es waren nicht einzelne, sondern das ganze Kollektiv funktioniert. Ich glaube, in den letzten vier Spielen gab es immer unterschiedliche Torschützen. Keiner hat öfter als einmal getroffen. Yildiz hat getroffen, Turam hat getroffen, Boga hat getroffen, der im Winter kam, den fiel es so. Was machen Sie mit dem? Der hat jetzt vier oder fünf wichtige Tore geschossen, kam ja aus Frankreich. Also den hat er sehr schnell gut eingebaut. Also ja, es funktioniert einfach. Die Mannschaft und Spalletti haben sich gefunden. Spalletti hat jetzt verlängert, was eigentlich auch nur total logisch war. Also das wäre, glaube ich, ein Frevel aus Juve sich gewesen, den nicht zu verlängern. Und dementsprechend, ja, schaut es bei Juve im Moment wirklich sehr, sehr positiv aus.
Nach Expected Points wären Sie tatsächlich zweiter, mit einem ordentlichen Vorsprung vor Milan. Ist natürlich nur eine statistische Größe, aber ein bisschen was sagst du dann doch aus. Aber wenn jetzt dann die Verbesserung kam, als die englischen Wochen weg waren und man sich ja jetzt gerade wieder reinspielt in englische Wochen, weil man in die Champions League kommt, nach allem wie es jetzt aussieht. Hat das eine Aussagekraft oder muss man sich davon lösen, weil es hat vielleicht jetzt diese Zeit gebraucht hat, dass Spalletti erst mal so seine Grundidee implementieren kann bei Juve und darauf kann man ja jetzt dann aufbauen in Zukunft?
Absolut. Also ich würde es schon so deutlich. Ich wollte nicht damit sagen, dass Spalletti nicht Doppelbelastung kann. Also das hat er mit Napoli auch sehr lange gemacht. Mir ging es nur darum, man darf ihn nicht vergessen. Er kam Ende Oktober, sprich dieser Kader ist 0,0 ein Lucianus-Spalletti-Kader. Also er musste mit dem arbeiten, was er hatte. Im Winter kam ja auch nicht viel. Spalletti hätte sehr gerne einen neuen gehabt. Noch mal vorne drin was Körperliches. Das konnte ihm der Pfarrei nicht erfüllen. Dann kam eben Bogard, wo viele gedacht haben, okay, der ist viel, aber keine körperliche neuen. Und den hat er jetzt schon zum Funktionieren gebracht. Also mein Punkt war nur, ich mache mir bei Spalletti keine Sorgen, dass der ab nächsten September nicht Doppelbelastung kann, sondern in der aktuellen Phase, wo er Ende Oktober kam, ein Kader, der 0,0 auf seine Hinweise gebaut wurde, glaube ich schon, dass die tägliche Arbeit mit so einem guten Fußballtrainer, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes Fußballlehrer, wenn du mit dem jetzt einfach seit knapp zwei Monaten unter der Woche, vom Montag bis Samstag, arbeiten kannst, glaube ich schon, dass es eben kein Zufall ist, dass es jetzt eben ergebnistechnisch auch greift. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, in den Wochen davor waren ja auch ein paar gute Sachen dabei. Gegen Galatasaray hätten sie auch in Unterzahl weiterkommen können, dieses wilde Rückspiel. Also, es gab ja davor auch schon gute Momente, aber jetzt wirkt es halt sehr stabil. Und das würde ich einfach Spalletti zugutehalten, dass er da jetzt schon was geschaffen hat, auf das du im nächsten Jahr aufbauen kannst. Und deswegen geht mein Blick wirklich auch schon Richtung nächste Saison. Ich habe es schon mal vor ein paar Wochen gesagt, ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass, wenn Juve im Sommer ein, zwei gute Transferentscheidungen trifft, dass Juve nächstes Jahr Spalletti und Scoletto Kandidat ist. Weil bei Milan und Napoli gibt es aus unterschiedlichen Dingen Fragezeichen. Also, Milan hat nächstes Jahr die Doppelperlastung, Napoli muss man schauen, was tut sich auf der Trainerposition. Also, das sind im Moment noch einige Fragezeichen. Inter wird klar nächstes Jahr auch wieder ganz vorne mit dabei sein. Aber ich traue wirklich Juve und Spalletti zu, dass sie dann über den Sommer diesen Step machen. Denn wir hatten es ja schon ein paar Mal, dürfen wir nicht vergessen, der Juve-Kader ist sehr jung. Also, Juve ist ja immer noch mit die jüngste Mannschaft der Liga. Also, ein sehr entwicklungsfähiger Kader. Jetzt hast du einen Trainer, der die Spieler entwickelt. Und dann möchte ich, da schließt sich jetzt auch der Kreis vorhin zur Premier League, dann möchte ich schon ein, zwei Namen fallen lassen, die bei Juve anscheinend sehr, sehr hoch im Kurs stehen. Uli hat gerade Bernardo Silva angesprochen. Der wird ja City verlassen, hat er öffentlich gemacht. Und es ist kein Geheimnis, dass Juve und Spalletti da sehr eng dran sind. Jetzt werden da logisch andere auch dran sein. Deswegen kann ich hier nicht sagen, was passieren wird.
Warum muss ich gerade um unsere Nationalteams-Folge denken, Bernie?
Du meinst wegen dem Alter, oder wie?
Ja, weil wir es jetzt gar nicht an einem Spieler festmachen. Aber es ist ja schon so das Thema, was wir damals auch hatten. Oder? Man hört sich lieber ein Extrembeispiel, Luca Modric, als dass ein junger Spieler eine Chance bekommt. Ja gut, aber bei Juve, wie gesagt, sind es ja viele.
Ja, genau. Also bei Juve hast du ja viel da, wenn du denkst, was Yildiz noch oben draufbacken kann, was ein Toram oben draufbacken kann. Also da hast du ja vieles, was auch noch den nächsten Schritt gehen kann. Und Bernardo Silva, ich war selber überrascht, Uli, ich habe jetzt mal nachgeschaut, der ist 32. Also Bernardo Silva ist jetzt so nicht 37 oder so. Das glaubt man, weil er seit 12 Jahren auf dem Niveau spielt. Aber er ist ein junger Mann. Und deswegen, ohne jetzt in die Glasklugel blicken zu können, aber falls es Juve schaffen sollte, Bernardo Silva zu holen, den in so einem Kader mit einem Trainer wie Spalletti, dann würde ich mal sagen Hut ab. Und der zweite Name, Juve will auf der Torhüterposition was tun, weil da waren die Gregorio und Berin einfach immer wieder schwankend diese Saison. Und da ist Alisson anscheinend ein großer Name von Liverpool. Auch da keine Ahnung, ob das passiert. Und ja, ich weiß, Alisson wäre auch nicht mehr der Jüngste. Aber Juve hat schon einen, wie sagt man, hat einen Kader, der entwicklungsfähig ist. Bei Juve würde ich jetzt nicht mit dem Kopf schütteln, wenn da ein, zwei Erfahrene auf hohem Niveau dazukommen. Und deswegen, klar, das ist jetzt zu weit nach vorne geblickt, aber Spalletti und Juve, das funktioniert. Und ich glaube schon, dass da einiges wieder auch mittelfristig sehr ins Positive drehen kann.
Alex, du wolltest noch was?
Ja, apropos Erfahrene hinzukommen. Ich habe gelesen, an Lewandowski fühlt man so ein bisschen vor, der ja ablösefrei ist. Und da sollen Milan und Juve, der ist ja der junge Mann, ist ja im besten Alter mit 37, also im besten Serie A und Italien-Alter. Vielleicht holt man sich da noch vorne einen erfahrenen Fox in the Box.
Ja, ob jetzt die alle drei dann finanziell zustimmen sind, da würde ich jetzt ein großes Fragezeichen setzen. Aber ja, es ist kein Zufall. Klar, da können wir auch mal eine eigene Folge machen. Logisch, das sind teilweise ablösefreie Spieler. Es spielt ja auch eine Rolle. Lewandowski könntest du eventuell so holen, Bernardo Silva. Also dementsprechend ist das sicherlich auch ein Thema. Aber ich glaube, dass bei Juve der Fokus schon sehr auf Bernardo Silva liegt. Und einen 32-jährigen Bernardo Silva würde ich mir, auch wenn den andere als alt bezeichnen, in der Form sehr gern dazu holen. Und letzter Punkt, denn wie gesagt, der Fußball, für den Spalletti steht, ist ja einer, der viel mit Ball, wo vieles fußballerische Elemente im Mittelpunkt steht. Wenn ich mir da jetzt Bernardo Silva nur eine Theorie dazu mixe, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass Spalletti da schon was Gutes drumherum bauen würde.
Da kann man echt gespannt drauf sein. Und ich meine, nachdem Bernardo Silva schon als der Piero bezeichnet wurde von Haaland, dann ist es vielleicht…
Dann wird es passen.
Vielleicht weiß der Erling auch schon was. So weit würde ich nicht gehen. Aber das war doch das nach dem Spiel gegen Arsenal. Also sehr interessant, was sich bei Juve tut und vor allem eben, deswegen fand ich es schön, dass du da jetzt auch noch mal länger drüber gesprochen hast, decken sich eben viele alte Klischees überhaupt nicht mehr mit dem aktuellen Juve. Das sollte man im Blick behalten. Auch wenn, merkt euch mal vor allem, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, sollte Juve dann nächste Saison in der Champions League gegen einen deutschen Verein spielen? Sollte wieder was erzählt werden mit einem 1 zu 0, das typische italienische Ergebnis und so, dann wisst ihr, nein.
So wird es aber bei Atletico auch wieder sein. Es hält sich ja auch seit vier Jahren dasselbe, obwohl es seit vier Jahren auch nicht mehr so ist, wenn es reicht.
Stimmt, da hast du wirklich recht. Es bleibt einfach sehr lange solche Klischees. Dann wollen wir aber noch mal nach Spanien gucken. Und Alex, das Klischee würde ja sagen, Real Madrid, die sammeln Titel ohne Ende. Und jetzt sieht es aber ganz anders aus. Und wir alle haben natürlich das Ausscheiden mitbekommen gegen den FC Bayern. Es ist auch gut, dass wir da keine Sendung aufgenommen haben. Da hätten wir bestimmt nur darüber geredet, wie Real nach Strich und Faden vom Schiedsrichter benachteiligt wurde. So wie es ja immer ist. Aber die Anadoks, die haben es nie leicht. Gerade in so einem Wettbewerb wie der Champions League. Wie ist denn inzwischen die Situation bei Real?
Ja, sie drohen zum zweiten Jahr, im zweiten Jahr in Folge, zum zweiten Mal in Folge, keinen Titel zu gewinnen. Und das ist ja schon super gauig für Real Madrid-Verhältnisse. Also es sind 9 Punkte Rückstand auf den FC Barcelona. Ja, es gibt noch einen Klassik. Also du könntest virtuell 3 hinzugewinnen und den anderen 3 wegnehmen, aber es sieht überhaupt nicht gut aus. Also im Klassik könnte Barcelona dann auch den Titel mehr oder weniger festmachen oder sogar bejubeln, je nachdem, wie es ausgeht. Auch die restlichen Wochen. Also ja, das wäre dann die Schmach. Die Kirche auf der Tor, der im Sinne einer Schmach 2 Jahre ohne Titel für die erfolgsverwöhnten Blancos ist schon heftig. Und ja, es gab letzte Woche keine Folge. Du sagst zum Glück, ich sag ein bisschen schade, dass es einiges zu besprechen geben. Aber wir wollen natürlich nicht, oder wir müssen Real Madrid natürlich deswegen thematisieren, eben aufgrund des Champions League Ausses, auch wenn es natürlich knapp, bitter, wie auch immer unglücklich war. Aber das große Ganze ist einfach eine Saison zum Vergessen, eine Saison mit enormen Problemen, mit Fehlern. Also verschiedene Verantwortliche haben da Fehler gemacht, Spieler natürlich auch. Und deswegen ist Real Madrid ein wichtiges Thema hier.
Was ist denn da jetzt aktuell die Stimmung? Ich habe jetzt neulich eine Statistik gelesen, weil jetzt ja Abel Loa fast so viele Spiele hat wie Xabi Alonso. Und sagen wir so, der Punkteschnitt wurde jetzt nicht wirklich besser unter ihm. Ist das auch so quasi eines der Themen? Ich habe neulich auch gelesen, aber da war ich an dunklen Orten des Internets, nämlich bei Reddit, dass Sebastian Hoeneß einer der Kandidaten auf den Trainer-Job sein sollte. Weiß ich jetzt nicht. Du musst dich nicht zu allem verhalten, was ich gerade gesagt habe. Aber spricht das gerade, also ist es stellvertretend für die Art und Weise, wie gerade bei Real diskutiert wird? Also, dass man auch Abel Loa schon wieder klar hinterfragt.
Ja, ich glaube nicht, dass er den Sommer überleben wird als Real-Coach. Das könnte ich mir gar nicht vorstellen. Oder ich wäre sehr überrascht, wenn es so kommt. Jetzt weiß man natürlich, die Beweggründe von Perez, dem allmächtigen Präsidenten sind natürlich vielfältig. Er wollte natürlich auch, ja, es der Mannschaft nicht so schwer machen, die natürlich unhappy war. Ich glaube, wir haben hier sicherlich an der einen oder anderen Stelle darüber gesprochen. Sie waren ja alle überfordert. Alonso hat so viel gesprochen und so viel Input und taktisch und jeden Tag so fleißig arbeiten. Und warum wird sich auf jeden Gegner vorbereitet? Und warum muss ich jetzt Laufwege studieren? Das war Vinicius und Co. alles viel zu viel und viel zu anstrengend. Und das braucht man gar nicht. Dann spiele ich nicht immer und werde ausgewechselt, wenn ich schwach bin oder wenn ich nicht mache, was der Trainer möchte. Das hat ihm gar nicht gepasst. Dann sind sie ihn losgeworden und wollten in Abellor einfach jemanden, der eher– ich glaube, Thierry Henry hat es bei CBS sehr, sehr schön gesagt, dass Xabi Alonso ein Coach war und Abellor ist ein Manager, so wie ein Zidane und ein Ancelotti eher Manager als Coach waren. Beides Legenden. Also ich will hier nichts wegnehmen, aber eher das Ego streicheln und eher gut zureden und eher wenig akribischer Fokus auf taktische Inhalte. Das war unter Alonso zu viel und Abellor war eben eher der Stadthalter des Präsidenten, der auf PKs natürlich auch immer gut Wetter macht und dann mal Barca wieder kritisiert oder die Schiedsrichter. Den Fokus lenkt auf Nebenkriegsschauplätze und die Mannschaft immer verhetschelt. Und Winnie Junior darf immer durchspielen, wann er will und darf machen, was er will und ein Papeh auch. Ja, und zu was das führt, hat man jetzt eben gesehen. Es ist eine Mannschaft, die in Momenten auch mit den Top-Teams mithalten können aufgrund ihrer individuellen Klasse und aufgrund dieses Champions League-Pedigrees, das niemand sonst hat. Aber im Großen und Ganzen ist das keine Top-Fußballmannschaft. Es ist als Team, als Mannschaft, als Unit keine gute Fußballmannschaft. Und da stehen wir natürlich beim Trainer und müssen die Position dann hinterfragen. Und das ist natürlich auch ein guter Blick auf den Sommer natürlich auch.
Und glaubst du aber, dass das jetzt dann der verspätete Umbruch ist? Also Real Madrid hat von der Transferstrategie her gesprochen, überspitzt gesagt darauf verzichtet, ein starkes Mittelfeldzentrum zu haben, was eben immer der Kern der Philosophie von Real war. Dass es da eben drei Spieler gibt, die ganz unterschiedliche Profile haben, die aber so ein gewisses Level nie unterschreiten in ihren Spielen. Und deswegen auch man eigentlich auf alles eine Antwort hat, was die Gegner anbieten können. Also glaubst du, jetzt wird man mit einer Saison Verspätung da auch rangehen und eben diesen Kader umstrukturieren? Oder ist es vielleicht auch alles gar nicht so wild? Weil wir haben ja auch gesehen, gegen Bayern war es auch knapp. Und ich habe jetzt natürlich die Schiedsrichter-Sprüche gemacht, weil ich finde, dass der Umgang mit dieser Niederlage jetzt nicht unbedingt so war, wie ich es mir gerne vorstellen würde, dass man eben mit Niederlagen auch umgeht. Aber es ist ja trotzdem ein Fakt, dass man auch mit ein bisschen mehr Glück definitiv diese beiden Spiele sogar hätte gewinnen können. Und dann wäre man gegen Bayern wie immer weitergekommen. Dann würden wir natürlich auch ganz anders über Real sprechen. Also, was sind denn dazu deine Gedanken?
Die Sache ist halt, wenn sie gegen die Bayern weitergekommen wären, und das wäre ja im Bereich des Möglichen gewesen. Im Hinspiel hatten sie Chancen. Da hatte Neujahr einen Fabeltag im Rückspiel, hat er das dann wieder mit dem Hintern eingerissen, was er da gemacht hat. Aber sie haben ja trotzdem dreimal geführt. Sie waren ja knapp dran. Und die rote Karte war auch ein bisschen unglücklich, ohne dass wir das jetzt aufmachen müssen, das Thema. Aber sie waren knapp dran. Sie hätten weiterkommen können. Sie haben, finde ich, sogar ihre besten Saisonleistungen auf die gesamte Saison gesehen. Finde ich in diesen beiden Spielen gegen die Bayern abgerufen. Und das ist schon bemerkenswert, wenn du die jede Woche in der Liga siehst, wie halbherzig, wie desinteressiert, wie demotiviert sie da auftreten und dann diese Spitzenleistung siehst gegen die Bayern. Denkst du dir schon, okay, sie haben das drin, warum zeigen sie es nie? Champions League ist für sie irgendwie was anderes, aber auf die gesamte Saison gesehen, sind sie völlig zurecht auch neun Punkte. Das ist ja ein großer Abstand hinter dem FC Barcelona. Völlig zurecht, das ist auf die gesamte Saison gesehen keine Spitzenmannschaft gewesen, in dem Sinne, wie es der eigene Anspruch ist. Natürlich bist du in der Liga immer oben dabei als Real Madrid, auch wenn du eine eher schwächere Saison hast, aber fußballerisch in so vielen Belangen ist das viel zu wenig und sie haben vieles zu adressieren im Sommer. Aber ob sie es machen, ist halt die Frage, weil sie haben es in den letzten Monaten, Jahren auch nicht gemacht. Also ich finde zum Beispiel, sie bräuchten einen richtigen Sechser. Ich glaube, sie werden ein Rotary holen, da haue ich mich jetzt mal einen raus, einen kleinen Hot Take. Ich glaube, der wird losgeeist von Man City oder kann ich mir gut vorstellen, sagen wir es mal so.
Praktisch, weil dann kann man weiter zur Weltfußballer-Gala geben, wenn er den Titel gewinnt. Zwei Fliegen, eine Klappe, das sage ich dazu.
Also da haben sie auf jeden Fall eine Baustelle auf der Sechser, eine Holding-Six, einen Anker-Sechser, den brauchen sie auf jeden Fall. Der ging ihnen ab, sind da eben ein bisschen zu dünn besetzt. Und dann haben sie hinten mehrere Baustellen. Also Carreras kamen für 60 Millionen von Benfica. Wenn du den spielen siehst, denkst du dir, warum genau hat man den für 60 geholt? Also rechtfertigt das gar nicht. Da ist er nicht so gut, ist er nicht. Und vorne hast du halt das ewige Problem. Vinicius Junior und Mbappé, die passen nicht gut zusammen. Sie pressen nicht gut zusammen. Sie haben keine Lust, Dinge zu machen, die sie nicht machen wollen. Also die beiden in ein Gefilde, in ein Gebilde zu kriegen in ein Team ist ganz, ganz schwer. Alonso scheiterte dran. Und da war ja eher dann Vinicius der Leidtragende, durch Auswechslung, durch nicht immer gespielt. Das hat ihm nicht geschmeckt. Und dann hat er sich wieder durchgesetzt. Und selbst wenn neuer Trainer kommen sollte, die beiden unter einen Hut bringen, ist ganz, ganz schwer. Man kennt ja ein Pape aus PSG-Zeiten, dass er da einfach auch schwierig sein kann, dass er natürlich möchte, dass die Dinge so laufen, wie er es will, dass er natürlich da spielen möchte, wo er es möchte. Ganz, ganz schwer. Also da eigentlich viele Baustellen, Trainer, Mannschafts-Building. Sie müssen sich verstärken auf verschiedenen Positionen. Es ist nicht so easy, das auch nur in einem Sommer zu machen, Max, ne?
Ja, ich wollte nur ganz kurz vorhin rein. Ich weiß nicht, ob die Erzählung, weil es vorhin ja viel Ancelotti und Zidane, dass es da ja oft nur ums Streicheln der Egos geht und so. Ich weiß nicht, ob die halt immer gerechtfertigt ist, weil ich glaube, Ancelotti und auch Zidane oder bei Ancelotti kann ich halt ein bisschen mehr sozusagen, weil ich verfolgt habe, sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob die Erzählung, die ja auch immer wieder halt durchgeht, ob das schon die ist, die passt, weil die waren halt sehr erfolgreich mit dieser Mannschaft. Und dann glaube ich, ist es vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr, als nur die Seele streicheln, sondern die hatten halt wahrscheinlich schon auch andere Skills. Sonst kannst du auf dem Niveau bei Real halt nicht Champions-League-Titel reinweis einführen und ich glaube, ein paar Meistertitel haben die auch gewonnen. Nur allgemein, ich finde, das hört man immer wieder. Ich weiß nicht, ob das sozusagen der zentrale Punkt ist. Ist so ein bisschen meine Meinung.
Also ich glaube das auch, dass da mehr Taktik mit involviert war, als so das Klischee sagt, was aber jetzt beim aktuellen Real wirklich auffällt, ist also Angelotti, sie dann, die hatten halt auch ihre Strategien auf dem Feld. Also du hattest ja Spieler, Toni Kroos, Luca Modric. Und andere, die denken eigentlich wie ein Trainer. Das heißt, die haben manchmal, glaube ich, auch durch Blickkontakt einfach so Dinge geregelt und dann ja, okay Trainer, wir machen schon, passt schon. Und das ist halt was, das geht dem aktuellen Real total ab. Also das fand ich schon in diesen beiden Spielen gegen Bayern auffällig. Wie gesagt, ich finde Real hätte da gut weiterkommen können und hätte sich Bayern auch nicht beschweren können. Also die haben da auch wirklich ihre Probleme gehabt. Aber wenn du dir eben in den schwierigen Phasen angeguckt hast, wer gibt denn da jetzt die Kommandos? Wer versucht denn da jetzt was zu verändern? Wie verteidigen wir das zum Beispiel in Unterzahl? Also du kannst dich natürlich über die gelb-rote Karte aufregen. Du musst aber trotzdem nicht Luis Dias mit einem langsam gespielten Doppelpass so viel Raum geben am eigenen Strafraum. Da war einfach die Positionierung nicht gut. Das gehört einfach zu diesem Ausscheid mit dazu. Und da fand ich schon interessant zu sehen, die haben sich schon Kommandos gegeben, aber es gab jetzt nicht irgendwie den einen, an dem du dich hättest orientieren können, sondern jeder hat da irgendwie so seine eigene Lösung gehabt. Und das, glaube ich, ist schon auch etwas, was aktuell zu beobachten ist bei Real. Aber ich gebe dir recht, ich finde auch, dass diese Klischees manchmal ein bisschen ungerecht sind.
Es ist natürlich simplifiziert dargestellt, um die Unterschiede heraus zu kristallisieren. Dass der eine Trainer eben ein sehr, sehr versessener Taktik-Freak war. Ich übertreibe jetzt auch mal wieder Alonso. Und dass der andere eben eher, ne, macht ihr mal. Und das passt eher in diese Man-Management-Schiene von den anderen beiden. Ich habe gesagt, ich fand es sehr, sehr passend, dass Henri das bei Siby erst mal gesagt hat und wollte ihn aufgreifen. Natürlich steckt da mehr dahinter. Aber grundsätzlich wurde Avelor installiert, damit er hier, ne, die Mannschaft mal ein bisschen auf Kurs bringt, durch eine andere Art und Weise als die zu taktisch verkopfte Trainerlehre von Xabi Alonso. Und ich finde, das ist ein Kandinalfehler gewesen, um da jetzt noch mal den Punkt zu schaffen zum Ausgangsthema. Ich glaube, genau das hätten sie gebraucht. Deswegen war ich auch sehr, sehr überrascht, dass es ja überhaupt nicht lange ging mit Alonso und dass sie auch die Geduld verloren haben und dass die Mannschaft rebelliert hat. Weil für mich genau so einen System-Coach braucht dieses Real Madrid. Sonst bleiben wir in der Schiene, wo sie sind, nämlich einzelne Hurra-Abende in der Champions League. Durch Hero Ball kannst du da auch durch individuelle Qualität, wie man sieht, auch den Bayern beikommen, der wahrscheinlich vielleicht besten Mannschaft Europas. Aber über lange Strecke und man weiß ja, dass die Meisterschaft der ehrlichste Wettbewerb ist. Auf Strecke gesehen reicht das nicht vom Niveau her. Das sieht man in der Liga auch anhand der Tabelle. Vielleicht sehen wir das auch im Klassikoo in 3-4 Wochen auf dem Platz selber. Diesen vermeintlichen Klassenunterschied, den es da gibt in der Qualität. Deswegen gibt es im Sommer viele Themen für Real Madrid, auch das Trainerthema bleibt man wieder bei Abellor. Ich kann es mir nicht vorstellen, weil er keinen Titel gewonnen hat und weil er auch viele Spiele verloren hat. Und Max, weil du es angesprochen hast, Alonso hat, glaube ich, sechs Spiele verloren. Gegen City, gegen Barca, gegen PSG, noch irgendwie zwei, drei Hochkaräter. Und Alonso Abellor hat verloren gegen Getafe, gegen Celta Vigo, gegen Osasuna, gegen keine Ahnung. Also eher andere Haliber. Und das spricht auch Bende.
Das spricht auch Bende. Aber auch interessante Aspekte, da müssen wir jetzt auch noch im Detail drauf eingehen, aber auch Fitness und Athletik ist, glaube ich, auch ein Thema. Ich habe ein Video gesehen von den Realspielern, das haben die bei Social Media gepostet, nach dem ersten Training unter Alonso. Und das war total witzig, weil alle die, die in der Premier League schon mal gespielt haben, und gesagt haben, mega geiles Training, hat voll Spaß gemacht und so weiter, und alle anderen waren einfach völlig KO. Und Fitness ist ein völlig unterschätzter Punkt der Alonso-Fußball-Philosophie, was Leverkusen immer gerannt ist in seinem Pressing. Das unterschätzt man so ein bisschen, weil halt der Ballbesitz so schön war. Und auch im Ballbesitz laufen sie viel. Aber gut, ich will jetzt nicht schon wieder das nächste Thema aufmachen, weil ich ja weiß, wir haben noch andere, über die wir sprechen müssen. Und da gibt es eben ein großes auch noch Uli in der Premier League. Chelsea hat aus den letzten sechs Spielen, also in der Liga, nur Niederlagen und auch in der Champions League und vor allem kein einziges Tor geschossen. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass man sich von Urosen Yoran, der ja quasi aus dem Multi-Club-Ownership hingewechselt ist, der einen ellenlangen Vertrag hatte, angeblich kostet die Entlassung 24 Millionen Euro an Abfindungen.
Fund sogar, glaube ich. Ich glaube sogar Pfund.
Fund sogar? Um Gottes willen, ey, Wahnsinn. Was ist das für Geld? Darf ich auch kurz Chelsea-Trainer sein? Ich mache das auch nur für drei Spieltage. Bei mir schießen sie auch keinen Tor.
Reicht dir auch, Max, für drei Spieltage, wenn du davor den 7-Jahres-Vertrag unterschrieben hast.
Ja, eben.
Alles easy. Genau.
Und alle ärgern sich auf Scheiße. Jetzt gibt es keinen Rasenfunk und wissen aber insgeheim, na ja, im Sommer ist er wieder da. Die paar Spielteile kriegen wir hin. Also, was ist da los, Uli? Denn ich habe, also die Ergebnisse sind natürlich katastrophal bei Chelsea. Und auch ganz, ganz viel bei Chelsea kommt gerade ins Wanken, auch von Investorenseite und so weiter und so fort. Aber ich habe unter anderem eine Grafik gesehen, wo die Expected Goals und die Expected Goals Against mit so einem rollierenden Durchschnitt gezeigt wurden. Und eigentlich hat da schon alles in die richtige Richtung gezeigt. Es zeigte sich halt bloß noch nicht in den Ergebnissen.
Ja, ist so. Also das Problem ist, das ist halt ganz, ganz, ganz viel Schichten dieses Thema. Und da ist, da ist Clearly Capital, Bluecore auch nicht ganz, glaube ich, unschuldig daran, dass das so viele Layer hat, dieses Thema. Ja, grundsätzlich finde ich das auch. Es schien auf dem Platz in die richtige Richtung zu gehen. Komischerweise würde ich einen kurzen Break machen beim Paris-Spiel in der Champions League. Denn da sind sie lange im Hinspiel noch gut dabei. Und dann geht das Ding völlig gegen sie und komplett nach hinten los und sie verlieren es sehr, sehr deutlich. Und seitdem ist das Team nicht mehr das Gleiche. Aber auch trotz und alle Damage gegen Brighton nicht, also diese 3-0-Liederlage am Dienstag, da hat er im ersten Durchgang was versucht, Rosengiorg, das hat nicht funktioniert. Okay. Aber im Spiel vorher gegen, ich glaube, Liverpool war es, wenn ich jetzt, ich hoffe, ich vermische es jetzt nicht, es ist sehr viel Fußball im Moment, aber ich glaube, Liverpool war es, da verlieren sie, meine ich, auch 3-0. Und das muss nicht 3-0 ausgehen. Das, wenn 1-0 für Chelsea ausgeht, ist auch okay. Oder 2-1. Also das können sie auch gewinnen. Und das kannst du in jedem Spiel eigentlich rausarbeiten. Er ist halt wohl, Rosengiorg daran auch mitunter gescheitert, dass er mit dem Wissen von Blue Coder installiert worden ist, dass er dieses Ding wie ein Hedgefonds führen würde. Das heißt, er hat nicht großartig viel Persönlichkeit, sondern er macht, was die Hierarchien von ihm wollen. Das wiederum hat dazu geführt, dass ihn viele Spieler überhaupt nicht ernst genommen haben. Dann hat er teilweise in Interviews auch etwas, was ich sehr gerne mag. Manchmal pathetisch, aber in allererster Linie sehr, sehr selbstbewusst gesprochen, was natürlich schwierig aufrechtzuerhalten ist, wenn es halt dann nicht läuft und hat aber auch hart durchgegriffen. Es gab zum Beispiel, nachdem Enzo Fernández den Berater gewechselt hat zu Pastore, und dann ging es los in Richtung, er würde gerne– Real Madrid ist auch schön so, glaube ich, ist ungefähr das Zitat gefallen, um sich zu positionieren für Real Madrid. Natürlich, logischerweise, da geht es jetzt weniger um Atletico. Und das wiederum hat aber auch wieder einen Ursprung. Also ich muss mich ein bisschen verschachteln, weil es einfach alles so kompliziert ist. Auch da, ein ewig langer Vertrag für Enzo Fernandes und nicht nur für ihn, also die gab es ja für alle, diese ewig langen Verträge. Und so ein bisschen das alte Scottie-Pippen-Prinzip. Die älteren Männer unter uns werden es sich noch erinnern. Du unterschreibst einen langfristigen Vertrag für eine super Summe, die zum Zeitpunkt nach den aktuellen Standards ein richtig guter Deal ist. Zwei Jahre später mit Inflation und einfach dem sich bewegenden Markt ist es gar kein guter Deal mehr. Und plötzlich hast du einen der bescheidensten Verträge. Auf deiner Seite, obwohl du dich ja selbst auch entwickelt hast. Das war bei Parma so, das war bei Enzo Fernandez so. So dass beide schon mehrfach auch intern aufgewertet worden sind in Sachen Verträgen, aber das reicht Fernandez nicht. Das heißt, er möchte noch mehr. Daher diese Aussage, die war auch genauso gemeint, auch wenn er es weiterhin zu negieren versucht. Und da hat ihn Roseno aus dem Kader genommen und das wiederum hat ihm sehr viel Zorn wohl intern eingebracht, weil es die Gruppe gibt, die es mit Fernandez hält. Und es kam jetzt gestern noch raus, es gab so diesen Spitznamen Aushilfslehrer für ihn intern. Also kurzum, das, was wir jetzt besprochen haben bei Abel Loa, Zidane oder Ancelotti und Alonso und so weiter. Da haben wir Fußballtrainer, die manchmal Schwierigkeiten haben, dieses extreme fußballerische Wissen an Charaktere zu übermitteln. Also sprich den Führungspart der ganzen Sache. Und das scheint bei Roseno auch so zu sein. Weil ich finde, so richtig viel gibt es ja jetzt nicht, es waren jetzt glaube 107 Tage oder so. Aber ich finde, dass da sehr viele, sehr gute Ansätze mit dabei waren. Der hat mich auch fast überrascht, muss ich sagen. Die ersten zwei Spiele waren Katastrophe. Danach habe ich ein paar Mal gesagt, oh tut mir leid, das habe ich falsch eingeschätzt, weil da waren richtig, richtig viele gute Sachen mit dabei. Aber ich habe das Gefühl, dass der aufgrund der Verpflichtungshistorie nie den Respekt der Mannschaft erfahren hat. Und dann laufen halt ein paar Dinge aus dem Ruder. Auch da muss man übrigens noch mal dazusagen, Chelsea hat weiterhin die jüngste Truppe der Liga. Das ist die flacheste Hierarchie, die man sich vorstellen kann. Weil der älteste Spieler, der halbwegs, das kann man halbwegs nennen, das ist das Spiel des Tossin in der Innenverteidigung, der auch so etwas wie der Integrator ist für die etwas jüngeren Spieler. Aber da ist kaum mal charakterlich ein großer Unterschied. Kureya ist wahrscheinlich noch am ehesten der Character, den du so brauchst und hast. Aber der ist halt keiner, der– also so scheint es zumindest– der jetzt nicht die Mannschaft großartig anzündet, sondern das ist jemand, der sich selbst halt permanent anzündet und den Gegner, wie wir wissen, andauernd. Manchmal auch die Schiedsrichter. Und unter dem Hintergrund wiederum muss man dann vielleicht nochmal die Mareska-Sache etwas anders bewerten. Weil Mareska ist ja Clubweltmeister geworden, wie wir wissen. Was im Übrigen auch, das darf man alles nicht vergessen. Wir alle haben nie gewusst, was macht es, wenn ein Team quasi den Sommer durchspielt. Jetzt hinten raus im April, wenn zum Beispiel City immer alles gewinnt. Ja, das kann schon einen Unterschied machen. Das kommt in der Diskussion auch in England überhaupt nicht vor. Was ich total sträflich finde, das nicht zu erwähnen. Dann muss man aber auch sagen, es hat zwischenzeitlich unter Mareska sehr statisch alles gewirkt. Also fast so übersystematisch. Du hast das Gefühl gehabt, keiner traut sich mehr mal, eine individuelle Bewegung zu machen, sondern es war nur noch Formationsfluss. Das hat auch mitunter ein bisschen gelähmt. Ist aber auch nicht ungewöhnlich bei solchen Trainern, dass es so Zwischensequenzen immer mal gibt, wo man das Gefühl hat, die bewegen sich gerade gar nicht, nur um dann den nächsten Schritt zu machen. Der sich ja wiederum so ein bisschen emanzipiert hatte von dieser ganzen Clearlay-Capital-Gruppe und für sich selber begonnen hat zu trommeln, was denen nicht gepasst hat. Deswegen war da der Finger auch sehr viel schneller am Abzug. Und deshalb haben sie auch Roseniork, glaube ich, verpflichtet, weil sie wussten, das ist ein Systemmann, der macht das, was wir von ihm wollen, weil so hat das in Frankreich auch durchgezogen, bei Strasbourg, ohne dass er großartig nachgefragt hätte. Und im Nachhinein muss man aber auch sagen, vielleicht hat dieses etwas härtere Regiment von Mareska, dieser jungen Truppe, eigentlich ganz gut gestanden, wohingegen Roseniork, so sagt man, etwas mehr auf Eigeninitiative gesetzt hat. Aber es ist ein superschwieriges Thema. Es ist viel zu früh, aus meiner Sicht, die Entlassung. Aber auch da wieder das letzte Stückchen von dem FC Chelsea, den ich mal kannte, das übrig geblieben ist, ist It's about trophies, it's about Champions League. Und wenn du dich nicht für die Champions League potenziell qualifizierst, dann bist halt weg. Und das wiederum kann ich dann nachvollziehen.
Alex?
Ja, du hast eine schöne Parallele zur Real, zur Abellora, zur Sharia Alonso, den vermeintlich besseren Coach entlassen und dann durch den Systemling, ich formuliere es mal absichtlich so, ersetzen, der dann nicht funktioniert. Und dann verpasst du alle Saisonziele. Das ist eine passende Parallele.
Ja, und gleichzeitig ist das Besondere an Chelsea. Aber da unterscheidet sich dann, dass ich weiß, dass in der Investmentwelt da nochmal ganz besonders drauf geblickt wird, denn Chelsea ist ein Multi-Club-Ownership-Konstrukt, das einen anderen Weg gehen wollte, das auch gedacht hat, denn man hätte das System ausgetribbelt, mit eben den ellenlangen Verträgen, dass du eben dann die Ablösesumme über die Zeit abschreiben kannst, wo du aber, du hast es ja auch schon angesprochen Uli, eben jetzt verschiedene Probleme feststellst, unter anderem auf der Spielerseite, dass die eben auch auf so einem langen Vertrag sitzen. Und das ist interessant, also auf einem langen Vertrag sitzen, der in Jahr 6 gar nicht mehr so gut aussieht, wie in Jahr 1, als er abgeschlossen wurde. Was interessant ist, weil eigentlich kennst du es aus dem U-Hash-Sport, dass da ständig Verträge dann restructured werden und so weiter und so fort. Das heißt, das hätten eigentlich die Investoren kommen sehen müssen. Gleichzeitig hat Chelsea das riesige Problem, also sie arbeiten angeblich noch auf so grob gesagt auf einer schwarzen Null. Das liegt aber einzig und allein am Gewinn der Club-Weltmeisterschaft im letzten Jahr, das dieses Jahr reingeht. Der höchste Einkommenstreiber bei ihnen ist das Champions-League-Geld, das reinkommt. Deswegen ist es so wichtig, die Champions League zu erreichen, denn ansonsten haben die jetzt seit der Übernahme hat Clear Lake über 700 Millionen Pfund Verlust gemacht bisher mit Chelsea. Und bei ihnen ist das TV-Geld und vor allem das internationale eben noch wichtiger, weil die Stadion-Einnahmen nicht so hoch sind. Also das Stadion ist ja ein Riesenthema bei Chelsea. War es auch schon, bevor die übernommen haben. Aber zum Vergleich, Manchester United nimmt mit einem Stadion, was ein bisschen größer ist von der Kapazität her als das von Chelsea, aber die nehmen einfach das Doppelte ein an Matchday-Revenue pro Saison. Das sind dann nochmal, ich glaube, 80 Millionen Pfund, die ihnen da fehlen. Also sprich, dieses ganze Investment, auch der Preis, zu dem Blueco und Clear Lake da reingegangen sind, die Art und Weise, wie man es aufgebaut hat, das hätte extrem, wenn es erfolgreich gewesen wäre, dann würden wir das jetzt überall sehen, dann würden das alle so machen. Gerade sind alle sehr, sehr froh, dass nur Chelsea diesen Weg gegangen ist, weil nämlich die Exit-Strategie gar nicht so klar ist, nachdem jetzt auch, sie dachten ja, sie hätten einen neuen Ort für Stadion gefunden, jetzt gibt es da den Bebauungsplan, auf einmal ist da gar kein Stadion mehr vorgesehen und sie sind auch so ein bisschen überrascht davon. Also neben all den sportlichen Themen, Uli, hat diese Zwiebel eben noch ganz viele andere Schichten.
Ja, du kannst es leider nicht, oder leider, ich weiß, es ist halt wie es ist, aber du kannst es nicht jeweils einzeln betrachten, weil sie haben sich selbst in dieses Problem manövriert. Das ist so der Erfolgsinparativ durch diese vielen Investments, die sie gemacht haben. Und man kann jetzt noch nicht mal sagen, das ist ja ein weiteres Problem. Ich meine, die hätten die Kohle, um einfach rein zu puttern. Aber dadurch, dass wir gelernt haben, dass die Nachhaltigkeitsregeln in der Premier League genauso hart durchgezogen werden, wie sie aufgesetzt sind, geht das ja nicht ohne weiteres. Das heißt, sie müssen irgendwann anfangen, sich selbst zu finanzieren. Es gibt halt von diesen schlechten Deals, da gibt es auch welche, die kannst du wieder veräußern irgendwann. Also bei Enzo Fernandes als Beispiel, der performt gut genug, dass man für den zumindest eine gewisse Ablösesumme nehmen kann.
Der will ja in der Drittwohnung, hat er gesagt, ne?
Genau, wenn man jetzt das Versus der bezahlten Ablösesumme sieht, dann ist das kein Gewinn mehr, weil ich würde tippen, sie kriegen das nicht hin, dass sie dafür nochmal extra, also die haben sie ja über, über, über bezahlt. Das ist ja auch so ein Blue-Code-Problem gewesen, dass sie damals gesagt haben, als der bei der WM performt hatte in Qatar, das ist der Spieler und man hat den intern so für die Hälfte ungefähr geschätzt. Und dann hat Beda Degbali gesagt, ja, aber können wir den kriegen? Ja, wenn wir halt überbezahlen, weil der hat schon woanders zugesagt. Ja, dann machen. Deshalb werden sie den vermutlich nie wieder persönlich bekommen, aber du kriegst für solche Spieler natürlich nur Ablösesumme. Das wird nicht das Problem sein. Nur, die bringt dich halt so gesehen gar nicht weiter, weil die ja erstmal nur ein Loch stopft, diese Ablösesumme, und du kannst ja nicht weiter ausgeben dann für ihn sozusagen. Und auf diese Verträge, die du zumindest noch vorhäußern kannst, kommen halt auch wahnsinnig miese Deals, die du nie wieder losbekommst. Also mich hat es zum Beispiel sehr gewundert, dass sie Armando Boya losbekommen haben. Kani Chokuemeca ist wahrscheinlich so das beste Beispiel. Das war noch die erste, da haben sie ja ein bisschen gelernt zumindest, das war noch die erste Clear-Lake-Capital-Idee, dass man einfach Spielern höhere Grundgehälter zahlt, damit sie zu ihnen kommen. In Chokuemeca-Fall ging es ja darum, auch englandweit ein Statement zu setzen, wenn wir die besten Jugendspieler wollen, bekommen wir sie. Später haben sie dann gelernt, sie müssen sehr viel stärker leistungsorientiert aufsetzen, diese Verträge. Also nur dann, wenn der Spieler das, das, das, das und das macht, dann kommt die Höhe des Grundgehalts zusammen. Bei Joko Emeka ist einfach nur ein völlig wirrer Betrag, eine Fantasie, den er halt natürlich nie hat reinspielen können und entsprechend wird es große Schwierigkeiten geben, solange der Vertrag läuft, dass den jemand eins zu eins übernimmt, es sei denn der Spieler ist natürlich bereit, davon etwas loszulassen. Und das sind die Probleme, die haben sie nicht bedacht, weil sie gedacht haben, das macht ja nichts. Wenn wir die 50 talentiertesten Spieler zwischen 19 und 23 aneinander rein, werden schon 25 davon durchgehen. Dann werden wir Champions League-Sieger und alles wird gut sein. Mit der Ausschussware– also das ist immer böd, über Menschen so zu reden– aber mit der Ausschussware aus ihrer Sicht, und sie reden ja gar nicht anders intern, haben sie halt nie auch nur ansatzweise zwei Sekunden geplant. Und im Übrigen auch Rosengior. Es gab intern überhaupt gar keine Idee, was denn passieren würde, wenn das nicht funktioniert. Genau. Die stehen jetzt da und haben keine Ahnung, was sie tun sollen. Schon wieder. Und ich war bei zwei, drei Prozessen, habe ich das glücklicherweise über eine Quelle erfahren, dass das genauso ist und war. Und es ist genauso wieder gerade. Die haben überhaupt 0,0 damit gerechnet. Und deshalb sind die jetzt davon total überrascht, dass das hat passieren können.
Jetzt rufen sie halt bei Fabregas an.
Ja, die werden den jetzt…
Ja, aber alle rufen bei Fabregas an.
Entschuldigung.
Genau. Dann sind sie nicht allein.
Dessen Telefon steht schon seit anderthalb Jahren hier.
Die werden den jetzt überzeugen mit einem 9-Jahres-Vertrag und noch höherem Grundgehalt. Wie sonst?
Weiß nicht, ob der sich mit sowas überzeugen lässt.
Da bin ich mir auch nicht so sicher nach dem, was ich so gehört habe. Also ich bin total gespannt. Und eben wie gesagt, es gibt quasi eine Investorensicht auf dieses ganze Chelsea. Zwischenzeitlich debakeln muss man, glaube ich, schon sagen. Die ist echt… Also das wird, glaube ich, auch formen, wie jetzt so der Zukunft, in Zukunft das Investment im Fußball aussieht. Also wir haben… Ich habe da ein Tribüngespräch zugemacht, weil CWC, die ja bei der DFL einsteigen wollten, bei denen läuft so gut bei ihren Sportgeschäften, dass sie die jetzt in ein eigenes Unternehmen ausgelagert haben und Geld und Kredite aufgenommen haben, weil sie damit zu viel Verlust gemacht haben. Es ist in Deutschland hier kaum berichtet worden. Und ich habe eben dann mit zwei Experten darüber gesprochen, was das heißt. Und ganz, ganz verkürzt gesagt ist es so, dass die Preise jetzt einfach viel zu hoch sind, dass diejenigen, die reingegangen sind in den letzten zwei bis fünf Jahren, mutmaßlich zu viel bezahlt haben. Und vor allem, dass es extrem schwierig ist, aus dem laufenden Geschäftsbetrieb Geld rauszuziehen als Investor. Denn die Vereine sind alle so auf Kante genäht, dass die letztlich alle auf einer schwarzen Null operieren. Das ergibt auch Sinn eigentlich aus der Logik der Vereine heraus, heißt aber für Investoren, dass sie nur dann Geld verdienen, wenn sie den Verein verkaufen wieder, also für einen Exit vorbereiten. Und das machen jetzt eben einige schon. Ich meine, bei Böli und Clear Lake wird ja auch darüber berichtet, die haben so eine professionelle Arbeitssituation gerade. Aber es könnte auch sein, dass der eine den anderen rauskauft oder umgedreht. Also Böli, dem nervt das Stadion-Thema unheimlich, nach dem, was man gerade so hört. Das ist aber die einzige Art und Weise, wie du aktuell so richtig Geld verdienen kannst mit diesen Investments. Die Einzigen, die ein bisschen Kohle verdienen, sind CWC in La Liga. Aber da sind es 150 Millionen Euro pro Jahr. Das ist nicht nennenswert für die. Es muss in Milliardenbeträgen sein, sonst funktioniert es nicht. Und das ist gerade ein Problem, in dem ganz viele Multi-Club-Ownership-Strukturen gerade drin sind. Und Chelsea ist da das allerbeste Beispiel, weil die es auch am aggressivsten gemacht haben. Weil sie auch dachten, sie sind schlauer als der Markt. Und jetzt stellt es sich raus, vielleicht doch nicht.
Sie denken es intern immer noch, kann ich dir sagen.
Ja gut, du ey, als ich mich wieder mit diesen ganzen Venture-Capital-Fonds und so weiter beschäftigt habe, die glauben, alle sie hätten eine Mozzarella erfunden. Es ist nicht aus, und ich habe da auch wieder viele Podcasts zur Vorbereitung gehört, nur unsympathische Arschlöcher. Sorry, ich muss es jetzt einfach mal so sagen. Aber Leute, die einfach zu viel Geld haben, die sind nicht mehr in der Lage, anders über die Welt zu denken, als eben mit Investment-Opportunities und zweistelligen Renditen. Und dass da überall Menschen arbeiten und dass es vielleicht auch gut wäre, wenn es auch anderen Menschen gut ginge, nicht nur der eigenen Firma. Das ist so weit weg von allem.
Ja, und einfach auch die Borniertheit zu denken, dass so gewachsene Vereine, die in der Community verankert sind und so weiter, dass du einfach, du lässt zwar den Badge gleich, aber du denkst einfach, du kannst innerhalb von einem Jahr einfach alles ändern, weil du bist viel cleverer, als dies je waren, obwohl die ein halbes Jahr zuvor die Champions League gewonnen haben. Also das ist schon auch, das finde ich, eine besondere Boniertheit irgendwie. Aber wahrscheinlich kommt das mit dem Erfolg, den sie halt ein Leben lang gehabt haben und vermutlich der Verblendung damit. Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist die…
Ganz kurz, wir haben jetzt keinen Frankreich-Experten hier, aber bei Straßburg funktioniert es sportlich tatsächlich ganz gut, was sie da machen. Ich bin da komplett weit weg, aber sie sind jetzt im Europa League-Finale, im… Für Frankreich Pokal, Halbfinale, Halbfinale, sorry, und im Finale des Frankreich Pokals. Und ich glaube, auf Europa League Champions League Kurs auch wieder. Also sportlich gesehen, bei Straßburg funktioniert es ganz gut.
Aber…
Leider. Ich habe immer auf Klamotten zu.
Ja, aber was verdienen sie damit? Nix. Sie gewinnen ein bisschen, selbst wenn sie die Champions League gewinnen, kriegen sie ein bisschen Kohle, ist nicht viel. Aber selbst wenn sie die Champions League gewinnen, wäre es ja nicht so, dass von, keine Ahnung, sagen wir, 100 Millionen Euro, die sie über die Champions League reinnehmen, 50 wieder rausfließen an den Investor. Sondern es gehen erst mal ganz viele in Prämien, es gehen welche in Transfers und so weiter und so fort. All die Gewinne, die realisiert werden, stehen in Bilanzen, aber die kommen nicht raus als Cashflow oder zumindest nicht in nennenswerter Absicht. Und das ist das Problem, das die Investoren haben.
Ich habe das schon sportlich betrachtet.
Ja, genau. Aber das ist denen ja wurscht.
Die haben schon vermandelt, ne?
Genau. Aber das ist eben das, was die Motoclub-Ownership-Strukturen feststellen, dass sportlicher Erfolg nicht bedeutet, wir verdienen damit Geld. Es gibt eine emotionale Rendite. So haben wir das in der Sendung auch rausgearbeitet. Ich werde es nochmal verlinken, liebe Hörneteure. Hört es euch gerne nochmal an. Es gibt eine emotionale Rendite. Aber Cash gibt es eigentlich nicht, weil das nicht rausfällt. Sogar die Manchester City Group, die haben über die gesamte Zeit hinweg gerechnet, über eine Milliarde US-Dollar-Verlust gemacht. Obwohl ja Manchester City all die Erfolge hatte. Die haben ja irgendwann chinesische Investoren reingeholt. Jetzt haben sie zuletzt Kredite aufgenommen. Die zahlen pro Jahr, ich glaube, wenn ich die Zahl richtig habe, 70 Millionen US-Dollar, nur an Zinsen für ihre Kredite, die sie aufgenommen haben, um das aktuelle Investment weiterlaufen zu lassen. Das heißt, sogar dieses Ding hat nicht funktioniert.
Zumindest haben die aber zwischenzeitlich diese emotionale Rendite auch monetarisieren können. Dass zumindest das Geschäftsergebnis allgemein poliert werden konnte oder kann. Zumindest ein Namen da sind. Minimum mal das, weil das ist bei Chelsea in die gegenläufige Richtung unterwegs. Dadurch, dass die, die halt ortsansässig sind, gar keinen Bock mehr drauf haben.
Ja, genau. Und das kommt noch mit dazu. Das stellen sie dann fest, auch im Moment finden uns ja alle gar nicht toll. Also ich verlinke die Sendung, könnt ihr sehr gerne anhören. Es gibt auch gerade eine Sportsau-Reportage dazu oder eine Doku. Die habe ich noch nicht gesehen, nachdem was ich gehört habe. Hört erstmal die Rasenfunk-Sendung, würde ich jetzt sagen. Weil ich glaube, da geht es ein bisschen tiefer rein. In den Dokus wird erstmal erklärt, was ist ein Multiclub-Ownership. Und ich glaube, da müssen wir jetzt beim Rasenfunk nicht anfangen, das nochmal zu erklären. Aber Chelsea, wirklich hochinteressant aus allen Dingen. Ich, ja, hat die Financial Times da neulich einen interessanten Artikel zu gehabt. Schicke ich euch später mal, also das geht nicht.
Rosengiorg könnte einem fast leidtun, wenn es nicht die 27 Millionen gäbe, weil irgendwie ist das schon ein blöder Knick, du gehst, weil die das so von dir wollen, von einem Verein zum anderen. Also er wollte das sicherlich schon auch so, aber du verlässt ein Projekt, das für dich einigermaßen funktioniert, was dir eine gute Zukunft gegeben hätte, um zu Chelsea zu gehen. Mit dem Wissen oder wahrscheinlich auch dem Auftrag, du hast dir ein paar Jahre Zeit und 107 Tage später bist du um 27 Millionen reicher, ob es dann 100 oder 1 Euro sind. Schau es dir jetzt erstmal zu.
Also ehrlich gesagt, mir tut er gar nicht leid, denn ich bin ganz, ganz sicher, dass neben dem Geld und so weiter, dass Roseno, der wird irgendwo einen Job bekommen. Weil jeder, der ein bisschen anders auf Fußball blickt und nicht in Chelsea drinne, der sieht ja die positiven Aspekte, die du angesprochen hast. Das heißt, den sehen wir dann. Ja gut, in der Bundesliga wahrscheinlich nicht, aber irgendwo.
Bei Tottenham in der 2. Liga.
Nee, die hohen, Eden Tersic habe ich jetzt gelesen.
Oh wei, oh wei.
Schon wieder.
Und Thiel oder was? Thiel und Tersic reunited?
Thiel und Tersic, ja. Aber das ist ja sowieso nochmal was komplett anderes.
Ich weiß Dinge, ich sage es euch, aber ich... Also Tersic wird es nicht, kann ich sagen.
Welche Dinge weißt du? Du darfst es nicht so antifizieren, du darfst es nicht sagen.
Nee, also Tersic ist nicht... Den haben sie diskutiert bei Tottenham, aber da gab es also kein klares Antivotum. Aber schon Dinge, die sich haben gegen ihn positionieren lassen. Wenn es einen eigenmaßen Sinn ergibt. Also bei De Zerbi waren deutlich mehr Pro-Stimmen da und bei Tersic war er in allen Trainergängen, also sowohl vor Frank als auch nach Frank als auch nach Tudor, jeweils ein Thema, aber jeweils gab es Informationen, die sie haben Abstand nehmen lassen davon.
Also Tottenheim wird sich dann im Sommer von De Zerbi trainen, nachdem sie ihm vor einem Monat einen 5-Jahres-Vertrag gegeben haben.
Das wäre die logische Konsequenz. Aber angeblich, er sagte ja oder sagte vor seinem 1. Spiel, er würde mitgehen in die 2. Liga. Und wir haben ja beim letzten Mal schon gelernt, dass es realistischer ist, als wir uns alle jemals hätten ausmalen können. Und das ist, also 2. Spiel, muss ich jetzt auch dazu sagen, ich will jetzt gerne Tottenham-Thema aufmachen, aber 2. Spiel, da konnte man schon was erkennen im 1. Aber im 2. Spiel habe ich jetzt was erkannt. Das war ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung. Das Problem ist, nur alle anderen haben auch wieder gepunktet. Das ist das Dumme für Tottenham.
Haben sie nicht in der Nachspielzeit sogar das Gegentor kassiert, Uli?
Tottenham, ja. Ja, genau. Ja, genau. Aber trotzdem ist es ja so weit okay gewesen. Und die anderen, also Nottingham gewinnt wieder. Leeds ist jetzt durch. Also die haben gestern ja auch unentschieden gespielt. Die sind durch. Und jetzt geht es nur noch. West Ham hat einfach wenigstens gepunktet. Und Nottingham, ja, das sind sie ja, die drei. Das wird noch ausmachen unter sich, ja.
Ja, du. Also ganz im Ernst, wer jemanden wie Mason Greenwald so verteidigt, der darf auch wegen mir gerne mindestens ein Jahr in der 2. Liga coach sein. Aber das ist nochmal ein ganz anderes Thema. Aber darf jetzt auch nicht so komplett unerwähnt bleiben, wenn wir über die Serbis sprechen. Wir schauen noch einmal nochmal nach Italien und dann kommen wir nochmal kurz zur Premier League. Christian, was hast du uns denn aus der Serie A noch mitgebracht? Moment, wir schauen noch zweimal nach Italien, sehe ich gerade. Hi, hi, hi.
Ja, machen wir ein bisschen kurz auf den Punkt gebracht. Ja, bei der Roma ist einiges am brodeln, und zwar jetzt weniger auf dem Spielfeld, sondern abseits. Und zwar die Herren Ranieri und Gasperini, haben sich da jetzt öffentlich in ordentlichen Disput verwickelt. Kurz Hintergrund, also Ranieri ist ja seit dieser Saison sozusagen berater, offizieller berater des Klubs, der Eigentümer, hat ja letztes Jahr noch die Roma übernommen, auch in die Europa League geführt, hat einen Platz frei gemacht. Ist jetzt auch so ein bisschen von Massara, vom Sportdirektor sozusagen, da ist so ein bisschen die Position drüber. Und Gasperini wurde ja eben geholt im Sommer, um da jetzt alles, das neue Projekt auf den Weg zu bringen. Und ja, kurz sportlich, die Roma ist im Moment punktgleich mit Kormor fünfter, eben der Rückstand auf Juve, sind jetzt fünf Punkte im Rennen mit Champions League, wird es halt schon sehr eng. Aber eben wie gesagt, was so plötzlich jetzt wirklich fast aus dem Nichts kam, ist, dass vor zehn Tagen oder so Ranieri in einem Interview vor dem Spiel, der ziemlich losgelädert hat, erst mal solche Sachen gesagt hat, wie ja, Ranieri war ja ungefähr die dritte oder die vierte Wahl, ich habe mit mehreren gesprochen und dann haben sich die Eigentümer halt für Gasperini entschieden und habe ich das durchgezogen, hat ihn sehr stark kritisiert sozusagen auch, hat gemeint, ja, alle Transfers, die wir auch in dieser Saison getätigt haben, da war überall der Trainer involviert, denn Gasperini, vielleicht erinnern sich ein paar von euch, ist schon einer, der auch immer wieder mal ganz gerne öffentlich so ein paar Spitzen setzt. Er hat jetzt im Winter zum Beispiel davon gesprochen, ja, ihr müsst mir bei der Roma schon sagen, was ihr möchtet, soll ich hier junge Spieler aufbauen oder wollt ihr, dass ich in die Champions League komme? Also, Gasperini ist da oft sehr ehrlich, sagt da manchmal auch ein paar Sachen, die sicherlich nicht immer clever sind. Und das Außergewöhnliche war jetzt einfach, ich glaube, wir kennen alle Claudia Ranieri, der seit Jahrzehnten im Spiel ist, der diesen Elder-States-Man-Rolle ja auch wirklich über lange Zeit pflegt. Und ich mir ganz sicher bin, dass er logischerweise wusste, wenn er solche Sachen öffentlich sagt, was da dann los ist, gerade auf einem heißen Pflaster wie Rom. Und da tun sich jetzt halt alle schwer, das ein bisschen einzuordnen, denn er hat damit jetzt unbedingt dem Verein nicht einen Gefallen getan. Und der Verein ist ja den, den er über alles liebt, weil Ranieri, die Geschichte haben wir hier oft erzählt, über mehrere Male die Roma übernommen hat, ist auf seinem Ruhestand für die Roma zurückgekommen, ist diesen Club durch und durch liebt. Und die Vermutung, wir saßen alle nicht dabei bei den Gesprächen zwischen Ranieri und Gasperini, ist halt, dass er sich da von Gasperinis Art ein bisschen provozieren hat lassen und jetzt so eine Diskussion ins Rollen gebracht hat, die halt leider auch dem Club schadet. Und das bin ich mir sicher, das will ich Ranieri 0,0 unterstellen, das wollte der ganz sicher nicht, aber Club ist das, was er mit am meisten liebt. Und ja, also es ist wirklich eine bisschen surreale Situation, ganz kurz noch dazu, vor dem letzten Spiel, die Romad gegen Atalanta gespielt. Gasperini hat lange nichts dazu gesagt, zu diesen Vorwürfen sozusagen. Und auf der Spieltagspressekonferenz, jetzt vor dem letzten Spiel gegen Atalanta, hat er am Ende geweint und ist aufgestanden, gegangen, weil sie ihn sozusagen übermannt hat. Hat er auch an seine Andri Perkassis, also die Eigentümer von Atalanta erinnert, hat gemeint, wir haben da jahrelang was aufgebaut. Alle haben an einem Strang gezogen und dann hat er angefangen zu weinen und ist aufgegangen und hat die Tür hinter sich zugeknallt. Hat sich da wirklich auch, du hast gemerkt, der war menschlich angefasst, hat auch so aufgezählt. Ich war jetzt acht Jahre bei Atalanta, davor neun Jahre bei Genua. Vielleicht bin ich gar kein so schlechter Mensch. Also auch, du hast gemerkt, diese menschliche Ebene auch. Deswegen ist das eine Situation, die ziemlich überraschend kam und die die ROME aber sehr beschäftigt. Denn im Moment ist schwer vorstellbar, dass nach der Saison da beide noch da sein werden. Also Gasperini als Trainer und Ranieri in dieser leitenden Übersichtsfunktion. Ja, sehr, sehr hitzige Situation im Moment.
Ach, verrückt, was die Nebengeschichten manchmal im Fußball auch ausmachen. Wie viele Minuten haben wir schon nicht mehr über Sportliches geredet, aber es ist ja wirklich ein wichtiges Thema.
Ein kleiner Satz noch, dass nicht alles an Ranieri hängen bleibt. Ich kann es ja auch von außen noch mal. Was da intern zwischen denen vorgefallen ist, können wir nicht bewerten. Wie gesagt, Gasperini hat schon immer wieder dieses, weil die haben im Winter zum Beispiel einen Robinho Vaz von Marseille, ein 19-Jähriger, für viel Geld, ich glaube für 20 Millionen Euro. Dann hat da auch Venturino einen von Gennot bekommen, für einen 18-Jährigen. Auf der anderen Seite hat er auch Malen bekommen, der jetzt, wie wir alle wissen, sehr gut funktioniert. Und dieses immer wieder von Gasperini halt so ein bisschen, was möchtet ihr denn von mir, soll ich was entwickeln oder möchtet ihr Gleicherfolg? Das muss halt Ranieri anscheinend getriggert haben, weil Ranieri ja auch für diese strategischen Entscheidungen logisch auch steht. Und deswegen ist er da, so er sich raus. Aber was da genau wirklich dazu geführt, das ist wirklich schwer zu bewerten, weil nochmal, wenn einer weiß, wie dieses mediale Game funktioniert, dann ist es Claudio Ranieri. Und dementsprechend, ja, bin mal gespannt, was da auch nach, dass es so noch passiert. Wie gesagt, im Moment schwer vorstellbar, das dabei. Auch, obwohl die Fridkens die US-Eigentümer, um auch wieder mal Investoren ins Spiel zu bringen, waren jetzt für Minuten lang nicht das Thema. Die hoffen anscheinend, dass sie beide ja noch mal an einen Tisch bekommen. Aber ob das klappt, glaube ich, kann man im Moment mal ein Fragezeichen dahinter setzen.
Das ist eigentlich mit einer der witzigsten Aspekte der Investoren im Fußball, die wir jetzt haben, weil die oft mit so McKinsey-Management-Strategien rangehen. Da muss man nun Assessment-Center machen und dann wird das schon alles funktionieren. Und dann treffen sie auf die Branche. Noch einen Call mehr einstellen. Ja, genau. Wir machen jetzt einfach immer so einen Road-Up-Call am Anfang der Woche. Da treffen wir uns dann alle und da besprechen wir mal kurz, wie die KPI-Zielerfolgung so aussieht. Und dann treffen sie auf die Branche Fußball.
Und dann zerplatzt so manches Seifenblas.
Wenn der blöde Fußball nicht immer wäre, dann wäre alles viel besser.
Ja, und also das kann ich jetzt auch mit Sicherheit sagen, dass in dem Moment, in dem Investoren in den Fußball besonders reingekommen sind in den letzten Jahren, wirklich das Erstaunen groß darüber war, dass diese Milliardenbranche so arbeitet, wie sie arbeitet. Und das hatte ich vorher schon gehört von Leuten, die ich kannte, die zu Fußballvereinen in Deutschland gewechselt sind, dass sie gesagt haben, du würdest es nicht glauben, wie wir hier arbeiten. Und das haben Investoren auch festgestellt. Und haben dann aber festgestellt, ach so, es reicht gar nicht, dass wir eine Datenbank hinstellen, dann wird alles besser. Ach so, naja, dann bezahlen wir jetzt jemanden sehr, sehr viel.
Aber Moneyball.
Ja, ja, ja, aber Moneyball.
Alles ist doch Moneyball.
Es ist alles Moneyball.
Um wirklich allerletzter Satz dazu, um den menschlichen Faktor noch reinzubringen, es war ja auch sehr gespannt, wie die Fanszene reagiert. Weil die hängen ja extrem an Ranieri. Aber viele gehen auch mit Gasperin, also erstens wollen die logisch nicht in Disput, aber viele haben ja auch verstanden, dass Gasperin jetzt mal möglich der Trainer ist, mit dem man jetzt halt das Neue starten kann. Und deswegen war jetzt dieses Heimspiegel in Atalanta, waren sehr gespannt, wie sie reagieren. Und ich finde, die Curva Sud hat da sehr besonnen und gut reagiert. Da gab es ein riesiges Spruchband im schönen römischen Reim und so. Ich bringe es jetzt einfach inhaltlich zusammen, wo sie gemeint haben, hey, so ungefähr die Roma steht über Alben, so bitte kriegt euch wieder ein im Sinne der Roma. Und das fand ich schon sehr schön, weil eben wie gesagt, das wirklich auch, glaube ich, aus Fansicht ganz schwierig ist, weil jeder Roma-Fan liebt Claudia Ranieri, da gibt es keinen einzigen. Und aber die Roma-Fans sind schon auch diesen Gasperiniweg jetzt mitgegangen seit letztem Sommer. Und deswegen fand ich das schön, dass sie sich jetzt nicht auf der einen oder einen oder anderen Seite positioniert haben, sondern auch da nochmal appelliert haben, komm, die Roma steht über Alben ungefähr, hockt euch zusammen, diskutiert das aus. Ja, mal schauen, ob das auch gelingt.
Wir werden es verfolgen. Und was wir auch verfolgen werden, ist der nächste ehemalige Bundesligatrainer in der Premier League. Bournemouth wird Marco Rose verpflichten. Die erste Frage, die sich da stellt, beim Blick auf die Tabelle, Platz 7 mit 49 Punkten. Man ist unter anderem vor Chelsea. Also Bournemouth ist eins der Probleme, das Chelsea gerade hat. Man hat seit– ich weiß gar nicht, wie vielen Spielen– nicht mehr verloren. Allerdings sind auch viele Uneschi mit dabei. Also warum gibt es denn da überhaupt eine Veränderung auf der Trainerbank? Und wie kam man dann auf Marco Rose?
Weil Iraolas Vertrag zum Saisonende ausläuft und er ihn nicht verlängern will. Und das hat er, ich glaube, am 15. April bekannt gegeben, wenngleich das auch schon jetzt nicht so ein großes Geheimnis war, dass das drohen könnte. Also es hat sowieso jetzt jahrelang schon gedroht, weil Iraola natürlich viel, viel Interesse auf sich gezogen hat, sodass man davon ausgehen hätte können, dass sie vielleicht rausgelöst wird aus dem Vertrag. Jetzt hat das aber selbst entschieden, dass das natürlich zum Ende kommt. Und deshalb musste Bournemouth jetzt reagieren. Und deshalb hat es aber auch nicht lange gedauert, bis sie dann einen potenziellen Nachfolger parat hätten für ihn. Und das ist jetzt Marko Rose.
Und passt das da in der Meinung nach? Also ehrlicherweise, ich habe jetzt nicht so den Spieß, wie von Bournemouth vor Augen.
Ja, passt gar nicht schlecht. Also es ist im Wesentlichen bei Bournemouth, und das ist dann so, das ist dann Iraola-Thema irgendwann mal. Der wird irgendwo bei einem größeren Team auftauchen. Da bin ich mir sehr, sehr sicher.
Auch Bill Bauer übrigens, wenn ich dazwischen gräbschen darf.
Das liest man sehr oft, dass er das wohl…
Weil werde, hört auf im Sommer.
Genau, das liest man sehr oft, dass er das gerne wohl auch übernehmen würde, aus persönlichen Gründen, logischerweise. Also der kommt ja aus demselben Jugendteam da, wie alle. Wie jeder einzelne Trainer auf dieser Welt, der Erfolg hatte in den letzten drei Jahren. Es ist im Wesentlichen Aggression, Disziplin, aber ausschließlich gegen den Ball gerichtet, relativ basic am Ball. Das würde ich gerne sehen von ihm. Fairerweise muss man auch sagen, dem ist jedes Mal jeder Leistungsträger unter dem Hintern davon verkauft worden, sodass das eher für ihn spricht, dass es nie eingebrochen ist. Im Gegenteil, sie sich sogar immer noch Saison für Saison verbessern. Aber ich würde es trotzdem gerne sehen. Man steckt im Übrigen nicht in Booten, aber er fährt im selben Boot wie Oliver Glasner, dem ungefähr der gleiche Ruf voraus eilt in der Premier League. Die werden sich auch ungefähr um die gleichen Jobs streiten, minus jetzt ausgeklammert mal Bebauung, wenn das passieren sollte. Dann kann es schon sein, dass das da nicht passiert. Aber ansonsten sind die beiden relativ im selben Fahrwasser unterwegs. Aber gegen den Ball, super. Du kannst immer erkennen, von Spiel zu Spiel, von Monat zu Monat in der Premier League, wie viel besser alles funktioniert bei ihm. Und wie er sie einfach drillt dazu, saubere, lange Bälle zu spielen, aber auch taktische Fouls. Siehst du, wahnsinnig clever, dass sie viel weniger in der eigenen Hälfte faulen als in der gegnerischen Hälfte, um direkt schon Dinge einfach gar nicht passieren zu lassen. Viele Fouls, wenig hart und dann eben sehr, sehr viel auch im Kaderbau. Also da wird ziemlich clever gearbeitet, sehr, sehr viel im Kaderbau so eingekauft, damit man auch so ein Umschaltsystem nutzen kann. Und wenn ich das jetzt so sage, dann glaube ich, ist das fast ein Charakterzug, den Marco Rose so auch hat. Ich habe immer gefunden, am Ball, na ja, aber gegen den Ball, wenn er sich darauf beschränkt hat, ja, dann passt das ganz gut. Von daher, ja, das einzige Problem, was ich habe dabei ist, dass Rose ja auch öffentlich ziemlich unglücklich war über das Arbeiten mit ausschließlich Talenten und relativ wenig Perspektive mit erfahrenen Spielern oder mal irgendwas zu erreichen. Und das wird jetzt hier nochmal zum Exzess getrieben, weil da ist ein Geschäftsmodell bei Bournemouth dahinter. In dem Fall ist es Bill Foley, der da sein Ding da hat, Black Knight Konsortium. Da gibt es ja auch wieder ein paar, was haben wir, Lurian ist glaubt drin, Hibernian, also die Hips, die Original. Dann Oakland und Morai Rense oder Moen, wie man in Portugal wahrscheinlich sagen würde. Einfach so und das ist auch nur ein Geschäftsmodell da, das hat auch für sie jetzt funktioniert. Auf den ersten Blick passt es. Auf den zweiten Blick bin ich total auch gespannt, wie Rose auch klarkommt an der Südküste, weil das ist noch mal ein eigenes Völkchen da in England. Sein Englisch ist solala, wenn ich das richtig weiß. Und er ist dann schon auch jemand, der irgendwann mal fordernd wird. Also ich bin sehr gespannt. Aber rein spielerisch auf den ersten Blick habe ich gedacht, nachdem ich zwei Umdrehungen gebraucht habe, ja, ja, eigentlich ja.
Ja, interessant, dass immer noch so viele in der Bundesliga auch tätige Trainer in der Premier League landen, also nach Hürzela und Fahke, wobei der eigentlich fast eher ein Premier League Trainer ist, als ein Bundesligatrainer und ehrlich ist, und Uli Glasner jetzt dann der Vierte in dieser Reihe. Sind wir mal gespannt, wie es läuft bei Bournemouth. Und dann wollen wir nochmal nach Italien blicken, Christian. Denn auch da gab es im Pokalfinale schöne Geschichten, die man erzählen kann.
Genau, im Pokalhalbfinale, richtig. Genau, Aktualität, Dienstag und Mittwoch wurde gespielt, ganz kurz. Das Finale lautet jetzt Inter gegen Lazio. Inter hat sich gegen Como durchgesetzt, war sehr spektakulär. Das Rückspiel Como hat 2-0 geführt in der zweiten Halbzeit der Insan Siro nach dem 0-0 im Hinspiel. Ja, und dann hat Inter das noch mit drei Toren gedreht. Celanolo, Doppelpack, starke Vorstellung. Also Inter jetzt mit der Riesenchance aufs Dubel. Und im anderen Halbfinale war Atalanta gegen Lazio, also für beide die große Chance, Titel, ja, Titel Sehnsucht zu befriedigen. Das war sehr spektakulär. Hinspiel schon 2-2, Rückspiel 2-2. Es ging ins Elfmeterschießen und jetzt kommen wir kurz auf den Herren, der ja da jetzt im Impelpunkt steht. Das Elfmeterschießen hat angefangen mit 2 Lazio-Fehlschüssen, die ersten zwei. Und Lazio hat das Elfmeterschießen trotzdem gewonnen, innerhalb der 5 Schützen, weil ein gewisser Eduardo Motta, 21 Jahre jung, Torhüter von Lazio, einfach mal 4 Elfmeter in Folge pariert hat. Und dieser Herr Motta ist eine schöne Geschichte. Da kann ich jetzt sogar die Brücke zum Premier League-Thema auch schön schließen. Denn die Lazio-Torhüter im Winter waren Providel und Mandas. Providel war lange schon bei Lazio die 1, Mandas, junger Grieche, war die letzten Jahre sehr aufstremt. Den hat Lazio im Winter für 20 Millionen Euro an Bournemous verkauft, um jetzt hier schön den Kreis zu schließen. Was Herrn Sarri, den Trainer von Lazio, alles andere als amüsiert hat. Der hat damals gesagt, das können wir nicht machen, wir haben dann nur noch Providel, wenn dem was passiert, was machen wir dann? Hat der Verein trotzdem gemacht, langes Thema, Lazio tun Verkäufe auch sehr gut. Der Fakt war, dass kurze Zeit später sich wirklich Providel schwer verletzt hat, monatelang ausgefallen ist. Und Lazio hat im Winter diesen Eduardo Mota aus der 2. Liga von Reggiana, vom letztplatzierten der 2. Liga, für eine Million Euro geholt. Providel verletzt sich schwer. Jetzt spielt dieser Mota seit Anfang März. Und er spielt richtig gut. Es geht eben nicht nur um diese vier gehaltenen Elfmeter. Das ist jetzt logisch die Geschichte der Saison. Aber Mota war auch in der Liga unter ihm. Hat Lazio nur noch einmal verloren seit Anfang März. Die haben Milan geschlagen, die haben Napoli geschlagen, die haben Bologna geschlagen. Mota hat auch da in der Liga in Bologna Elfmeter gegen Orsullini gehalten, sprich, seine aktuelle Elfmeter-Statistik sind 6 Elfmeter, 5 davon gehalten in den letzten zwei Monaten. Und eben wie gesagt, jetzt bitte nicht nur auf die Elfmeter reduzieren, sondern der hat einen richtig guten Eindruck gemacht. 21 Jahre jung, vom Tabellenletzten der 2. Liga für eine Million Euro geholt. Das ist die Geschichte im Moment bei Lazio. Stammt aus der Jugend von Juve, war dann viel, wie man es von italienischen jungen Spielern kennt, wurde immer wieder ausgeliehen, mal da an Laia, mal da an Laia, mal da an Laia. Und jetzt unter der Skepsis des eigenen Clubs fährt er jetzt so auf, bringt Lazio ins Pokalfinale. Wie wir alle wissen, das Pokalfinale findet in Italien im Rom statt. Auch da gibt es dieses wunderschöne 50-50 bei den Kurven mit 25.000 Mann. Lazio hat jetzt sozusagen ein kleines Heimspiel im Finale. Der letzte Punkt dazu, die Frage ist, füllen sie es auch, denn Lazio, die Lazio-Fans haben die letzten Wochen teilweise die Heimspiele boikottiert, weil das Verhältnis zu Club Boslo Tito sehr angespannt ist. Es gab zuletzt Lazio-Heimspiele mit 4.000 oder 5.000 Zuschauern. Und Maurizio Sarri, der jetzt wirklich auch den ersten Titel mit Lazio gewinnen kann, hat nur gemeint, jetzt nach dem Elfmeterschießen mein größter Traum ist, dass hoffentlich alle Lazio-Fans eben zum Finale kommen und das Stadion voll machen. Ich glaube, das wird auch passieren, weil es logisch in der Heimat statt im Pokalfinale zu haben, was ganz besonders ist. Und dieser Herr Eduardo Motta schreibt im Prinzip ja so ein bisschen im Moment das kleine italienische Fußballmärchen. Und ist ein Beweis dafür, dass es in der 2. Liga in Italien auch einige gute, talentierte, junge Italiener gibt, denen man vielleicht auch hin und wieder auch eine Chance geben könnte in der 1. Liga.
Nicht schon mal Musiala in die Serie B stecken.
Zum Beispiel. Ja, zwar wollen wir Motta nicht zu Musiala machen, aber ob er so viel Talent mitbringt, würde ich mal ein Fragezeichen dahinter setzen. Nee, aber es ist logisch eine besondere Geschichte. Also, dass da man ja noch beim Tabellenletzten der 2. Liga. Und wie gesagt, nicht nur die Elfmeter, weil ich glaube, das wissen wir alle. Klar kann Torhüter auch mal ein paar Elfmeter halten, aber der hat wirklich Ruhe ausgestrahlt auch in der Liga. Wie gesagt, Milan geschlagen, Napoli geschlagen, Bologna geschlagen, nur einmal verloren. Jetzt noch dieses Stück oben drauf. Ja, ich glaube, Sarri ist mittlerweile auch von Motta überzeugt.
Nicht verwandt und verschwägert, übrigens mit anderen bekannten Mottas.
Mottas, nee, definitiv nicht.
Diese Mottin wäre jetzt die richtige Mehrzahl gewesen.
Es müsste ja A-Konjugation sein, dann wäre es ja Motte. Aber das ist ja komplett anders. Ich dachte nur, weil wir schon so häufig über quasi Zöglinge von ehemaligen Profis gesprochen haben, dass ich es dann lieber hier nochmal mit dazu sage.
Aber habt ihr als Erinnerung, habt ihr schon mal ein Elfmeterschießen in Erinnerung, wo vier in Folge und zwar auch alle gehalten, also nicht verschossen, der hat die alle gehalten. Schon sehr außergewöhnlich, oder? Also mir ist nichts eingefallen.
Es gab mal eins bei der Frauen-WM 2015 im Viertelfinale, glaube ich, ne Viertelfinale war das dann. Aber da wurden auch so wahnsinnig viele nacheinander verschossen. Aber es ist irre. Vor allem, ich habe es nicht mitbekommen, ich habe es jetzt nur durch dich mitbekommen, deswegen vielen Dank. Aber das muss ich ja auch unglaublich anfühlen. Du trist den Ersten als Atalanta, dann verschießt Lazio für zwei in Serie. Aber das heißt, du führst quasi bis zum dritten Elfmeterschützen, führst du immer noch mit zwei zu eins. Und dann geht es auf die Linie.
Und gehst nach fünf Elfmetern als Verlierer raus. Die Geschichte musst du aus Atalantas Sicht auch erst mal schreiben. Definitiv.
Aber wirklich. Naja, ihr drei, das hat große Freude gemacht. Ich werde zwei Sendungen verlinken, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Die könntet ihr sehr gut jetzt nochmal anhören, wenn ihr sie noch nicht gehört habt. Zum einen eben, wie Investoren den Fußball umbauen. Ich glaube wirklich, dass da ein bisschen was drinsteckt, was ihr wahrscheinlich auch so noch nicht anderswo gehört habt, weil meinem Eindruck nach hat es eben einfach in Deutschland niemand so wirklich berichtet, was da bei CWC gerade so los ist. Und das ist ja nur der Startpunkt unserer Diskussion. Und die zweite Sendung ist eben die zum WM aus Italiens. Da haben wir eben über viele Themen gesprochen, die wir jetzt am Schluss jetzt auch nochmal so indirekt angesprochen haben. Junge italienischer Torhüter, der jetzt dann doch eine Chance bekommt in der Serie A. Freuen wir uns doch. Also ihr drei. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Herzlichen Dank an Uli Hebel. Danke dir.
Danke dir.
Vielen Dank an Alex Truica. War wie immer eine Freude, junger Mann.
Sehr gerne, junger Mann.
Und herzlichen Dank an Christian Bernhard.
Die Alten sind immer zu spät hier.
Ja, ich sag Danke, Max.
Und ich danke natürlich auch euch, lieben Hörerinnen und Hörer. Denn ihr wisst ja, alles im Rasenfunk ist paywall, werbe- Und ganz im Ernst, so wie sich Werbung im Podcast grad verändert, können wir alle nur drei Kreuze machen, dass dem so ist. Sowohl ihr als KonsumentInnen und ich als derjenige, der es produziert. Und ich muss es dann nur in anderen Podcasts hören. Also vielen, vielen Dank, dass ihr das möglich macht. Wie ihr uns Geld zukommen lassen könnt, das erfahrt ihr in der Podcast- und der Videobeschreibung. Oder in dem ihr auf rasenfunk.de geht und dort auf den Unterstützen-Button klickt. In dieser Folge möchte ich mich bedanken bei Ben Viva Soccer Gumos, schreibt er bei Tartan, Ami, bei Dirk, bei Neuer Nick und bei Sostenitori. Ganz herzlichen Dank für euren Support. Und wenn ihr Feedback habt zu dieser Sendung oder auch zu anderen, die ihr gehört habt, dann sehr gerne unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Freuen wir uns sehr drüber. Und wir würden uns natürlich auch freuen, wenn ihr diese Sendung hier weiterempfehlt. Denn da steckt ja doch so einiges drin, was vielleicht auch noch andere Fußballfans interessieren könnte. In diesem Sinne, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt uns gewogen und vor allem aber bleibt oder werdet gesund. Bis bald, macht's gut, ciao.
Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.